Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten.
Sag mal, was macht eigentlich so ein Hacker.
Tagsüber schlafen, nachts hacken und in der Zwischenzeit recht haben.
Logbuchnetzpolitik Nummer 443 vom, was sage ich denn jetzt?
Ja, das stimmt.
Äh
Irgendwie 13.12zehnter also wir nehmen diese Sendung etwas früher auf. Das äh sagen wir jetzt mal hier aus Transparenzgründen.
Wir wir wissen noch gar nicht, was am Freitag Schlimmes passiert.
Also wenn ihr jetzt da davon ausgeht, wir müssten auf den irgendwelchen Atomexplosionen oder sowas eingehen. Wir wissen von nichts. Wir haben keine Ahnung.
Und genau, wir veröffentlichen am Samstag, weil am Samstag eine Release des CCC,
stattfindet und eine Release ist äh maßgeblich äh Flippke und deswegen haben wir auch Flippke hier.
Genau, hallo Flutke. Moin. Du warst ja schon mal da,
bist ja quasi schon äh genau gehörst hier zum Bestand. Ich gucke grad mal, wann war denn das eigentlich? Das war.
420 glaube ich. Einundzwanzig.
21 hatten wir dich. Genau. Das Geld ist nicht weg. Es ist nur woanders hieß das und das war äh im Februar. Da haben wir uns über so ID-Wallett und äh all diese ganzen Hackereien, die du da veranstaltet äh hast, mit anderen zusammen.
Es waren noch Zeiten.
Unterhalten, genau. Und jetzt sind wir ja schon wieder äh einen Schritt weiter und wollen heute mal ganz viel über ja
Telematik, Infrastrukturen sprechen, sprich äh die Digitalisierung unserer,
in Deutschland aufnehmen. Das ist sozusagen jetzt heute das Thema, also eine kleine kleine Sondersendung. Gibt's sonst noch irgendwas zu berichten?
Weiß ich ja noch nicht.
Die ich meine so unabhängig davon wir sind ja noch ein Prolog. Da kann man ja da kann man ja alles reinschmeißen.
Ich wir wissen ja gar nicht, was passiert ist seit der letzten.
Keine Ahnung, ne?
Die letzte Sendung ist ja gerade mal zwei Tage her.
Ja und wir senden sozusagen in der Zukunft. Wir kennen noch nicht mal unsere Vergangenheit.
Noch nicht mehr. Wir wissen gar nicht in welcher Welt ihr uns hört oder oder wie viel davon übrig ist.
Ja, ob ihr uns überhaupt noch versteht, ob da überhaupt noch.
Gibt's uns schon gar nicht.
Es kann alles sein. Das kann kann das kann die letzte Botschaft gewesen sein. Wenn wir alles rausfinden oder ihr werdet das rausfinden, ihr wisst Bescheid. Ähm steigen wir doch einfach gleich äh ins Thema ein, oder?
Digitalisierung des Gesundheitswesens klingt äh,
Klingt bedrohlich, haben wir auch Feedback bekommen, hätte man noch verlesen können, dass das äh äh dass dass wir da teilweise zu äh zu negativ drüber denken,
und äh ja gut, das.
Wir sammeln das grad noch so ein bisschen, weil das ist natürlich auch ein äh komplexes Feld und deswegen machen wir jetzt auch die Sendung heute äh so wie wir sie machen,
Ähm
und ja haben auch äh vorher mal so ein bisschen vorne einen zu äh steigen. Also um es mal kurz äh vorweg äh zu nehmen, du hast so ein paar Hackereien äh veranstaltet, die werden jetzt am Wochenende äh bekannt.
und daraus ergeben sich auch so ein paar
äh Handlungsoptionen für äh die Politik, die wollen wir jetzt alle mal äh besprechen, aber um das verstehen zu können müssen wir das mal ähm den Bogen ein bisschen breiter spannen und ähm,
tauchen mal so ein wenig in die in die Arztpraxen in äh Deutschland ein,
ähm ja in zunehmenden Maße digital werden.
Zwangsdigitalisiert werden die ja eigentlich auch, oder.
Das haben wir jetzt ja schon schon seit einiger Zeit, also schon seit 2tausendsiebzehn haben wir ja diese Telematik Infrastruktur.
Die aber auch andere Sachen, da auch Termine, will man ja auch irgendwie haben. Also es ist ja, es ist ja eigentlich eine ganze Menge zu holen in dieser ganzen Welt und wir leben ja immer in dieser in in dieser problematischen Chancen und Risiken abwägen äh die Rotomie
Und ähm ja, aber wir wollen natürlich vor allem diese ganzen Prozesse, die derzeit noch mühsam, bürokratisch, langsam,
auch äh fehleranfällig sind. Da würden wir natürlich gerne das,
Segenswerk der der Digitalisierung angewendet sehen, aber es hat ja auch mal so ein bisschen seine Probleme. Und ähm
Da gab's jetzt einen längeren Plan und wir haben ja jetzt auch in der letzten Sendung auch schon drüber gesprochen. Es gibt vor allem eine eine Unternehmung, nämlich diese Thematik, was sozusagen das die Sammlungsbewegung aller im Gesundheitssystem beteiligten.
Partner äh repräsentiert und die technische Lösung einführen.
EV sind ein Verein.
Nee, ist eine ist eine GmbH tatsächlich, die gehört zu 51 Prozent dem BMG, wird also.
Ministerium für Gesundheit, ja.
Genau, wird also quasi von der Politik durchregiert, wenn man so will und die denken sich Spezifikationen und Verfahren für das Gesundheitswesen aus.
Um das zu also was jetzt erstmal keine schlechte Idee ist, dass man sagt so wir wollen digitales Gesundheitswesen haben, wir schaffen eine wirtschaftliche Institution,
und die wird die kriegt von Gesetzen strecken, also größtenteils von Gesetzen glaube ich Vorgaben ja.
Es gibt so ein paar gesetzliche Vorgaben, wie sich das Ganze auszugestalten hat und die GEMAtik denkt sich dann konkret aus, wie das technisch realisiert wird
erzeugter produzierter Spezifikation, die dann von Herstellern implementiert werden,
und die Thematik ist unter anderem dafür verantwortlich diese Telematik Infrastruktur zu betreiben und zu verantworten.
Also ein ein Ökosystem, in dem es auch äh Hersteller gibt von unterschiedlichen Systemen, die einem,
die Standards folgen.
Genau, also zum Beispiel.
Infrastruktur zusammenarbeiten und die wiederum wird aber von der Gamatik unterhalten.
Ähm von unterschiedlichen Herstellern, die das dann implementieren, backendseitig. Ähm da sprechen wir dann zum Beispiel über die ähm elektronische Patientenakte.
oder das E-Rezept, die dann innerhalb dieser Telematik-Infrastruktur oder mit Hilfe der Telematik-Infrastruktur realisiert werden und.
Das das E-Rezept Wire kürzt sich bei uns Thema, auch weil du dir das angeschaut hast, also äh wer äh dein dein Schaffen und Zerstören äh verfolgt, äh weiß,
dass dass du dir seit einiger Zeit dich dich so ein bisschen mit auseinandersetzt mit Digitalisierung des Gesundheitswesens.
Ich würde ähm mal damit anfangen, dass wir ähm vielleicht erstmal so beschreiben, wie diese Digitalisierung
vorangegangen ist und es fing halt alles an mit dieser Gesundheitskarte und das war sozusagen der erste Schritt, weil wenn man überhaupt erstmal irgendwas digitalisieren will, muss man irgendwie erstmal Datenbestand äh haben und vor allem sollten ja die,
Praxen die Möglichkeit haben,
einfach mal alles sofort zu erfassen, ohne gleich wieder äh alles eintippen zu müssen. Das ist ja eigentlich auch ein Feature, dass man diese Krankenkassen oder Krankenversicherungskarten äh hat oder wie heißt der eigentlich, Gesundheitskarte.
Die elektronische Gesundheitskarte.
Genau, die die EGK, genau, Gesundheitskarte, aber im Prinzip ist es eine Patientenidentifikation, ne? Genau. Was ist da drauf auf dieser Karte?
Da steht dein Name drauf, deine Krankenversichertennummer und optional auch noch so ein paar Notfallmedizinische Daten, aber Basicly steht da drauf, wer du bist.
Und es handelt sich dabei um eine normale Chipkarte.
Ist eine Smartcard, genau. Die hat auch eine PIN, die wissen leider nur die wenigsten, weil die Kranken äh Kassen, die nicht ausgehen und ähm genau, das ist so eine Identitätskarte. Did eine Pin.
Die hat eine PIN. Was was würde diese PIN dann noch äh bewirken können, wenn man die weiß.
Wenn man die weiß, dann kann man damit so kryptografische Operationen machen und sich in seiner elektronischen Patientenakte anmelden, ihr Rezepte abrufen und so weiter und so fort.
Mhm, aber die hat keiner.
Die hat keiner, weil die Krankenkassen nicht verpflichtet waren, die auszuhändigen.
Aber der kommen wir vielleicht später zu. Also erstmal kann ich das meinen im Prinzip ist es doch ein Versicherungsnachweis. Oder oder ein äh diese Person,
kann bei dir, liebe Ärztin, Leistung beziehen und wir bürgen damit, dass wir bürgen dafür, dass die dass die bei uns Beiträge zahlt und wir deswegen auch die Rechnungen bezahlen.
in erster Ausbaustufe von dem, was Tim jetzt meint.
Ja richtig, dafür gibt es innerhalb dieser Telematik-Infrastruktur einen Service, der nennt sich Versicherten, Stammdatenmanagement, kurz VSDM,
und ähm damit ist es möglich, wenn die ähm EGK gesteckt wird in so einen Smartkarten wieder beim Arzt. Da kann der Arzt die Identität auslesen und zu der Versicherung hingehen und kann fragen, du hör mal, sag mal,
Hier ist der Patient eigentlich tatsächlich versichert, zahlt der Beiträge und dann hat der Arzt die Bestätigung, jawoll, das versichert und,
Die Versicherung hat gleichzeitig den Beweis, dass dieser Patient, diese Patientin gerade tatsächlich in der Arztpraxis war oder ist.
Und vielleicht sage ich mal den Begriff abzuräumen. Also wenn wir von TI oder Telematik Infrastruktur sprechen, dann reden wir von diesem Gesamtsystem, was diese Thematik,
umsetzt und was sozusagen jetzt deutschlandweit betrieben wird, dass es sozusagen die Infrastruktur, in die sich jede Arztpraxis einkoppelt.
Das korrekt, ja. Das ist so der Überbegriff äh für diese ganzen Anwendungen.
der umfasst aber auch die elektronische Patientenakte, das E-Rezept und weitere Anwendungen. Im Grunde genommen ist das ein Netzwerk, ein IP-Netzwerk, wo dann so Serverdienste drinstehen.
Die unterstützen die unterschiedlichen Anwendungsfälle zwischen Arzt oder Arztpraxis, Ärztin, Patient, Patientin und äh Krankenkasse.
Genau und da gibt's auch noch weitere Akteure, die da dran teilnehmen, zum Beispiel Apotheken haben auch einen Zugang zu dieser Telematik-Infrastruktur.
Weil es ja Rezepte gibt, die potenziell mal eingelöst werden.
Ganz genau richtig.
Und weil sie halt einfach Mitspieler sind in diesem ganzen System.
Also die Standardprozesse des Gesundheitswesens, die Klassiker. Hingehen,
jemand anders zahlt die Rechnung, Rezept kriegen, jemand anders zahlt die Rechnung, aber man muss einen Teil davon zahlen. Das bilden die alles digital ab.
Also im Prinzip unser äh unser verteiltes Betriebssystem für das Gesundheitswesen. Wenn ich jetzt mit der Karte zum Arzt gehe und da sage, hier nimm mal, lese mal, was passiert dann genau?
Da muss ich jetzt weiter ausholen. Also ähm du steckst dir deinen Kartenterminal rein, dieses Kartenterminal ist mit einem Broader verbunden, mit so einem TE-Connector, kann ich gerne gleich auch nochmal weiter erläutern, was das ist.
und dann werden erstmal deine Daten von dieser Karte abgelesen. Die stehen da im Plan Text drauf, die kann man einfach so auslesen. Ich könnte jetzt auch deine EGK hernehmen, die hier in Smart Karten wieder stecken und kann dir sagen, wer du bist.
Sehr gut.
Ne? Du weißt.
Weiß sogar, welcher Name da außer Tim Fritlov noch steht. Ja, Francis.
Vornamen halt.
Damit weiß ich erst mal, wer du bist,
geht der Arzt, also nicht der Arzt, sondern die Praxensoftware, die das Primärsystem nennt sich das, zu dem Versicherer und äh fragt dann mal nach, hast du den schon mal gesehen? Und dann sagt die Versicherung, jawoll, kennen wir, ist bei uns versichert.
Also das findet tatsächlich dann auch immer online statt.
Genau, diese Überprüfung findet online statt,
und der Arzt hat dann eine Bestätigung, dass du tatsächlich in der Arztpraxis da zu dem Zeitpunkt dort warst und kann das wiederum dann benutzen später, um mit der Krankenversicherung von dir abzurechnen
was auch für immer für Dienstleistungen er dann da.
Allein das Auslesen dieser Karte ist schon ein Beweis, dass ich da war.
In Zusammenhang mit der Kommunikation mit diesen versicherten Stammdaten.
Mhm. Und diese Karte kann man nicht einfach so duplizieren.
Idealerweise nicht. Ich habe mir jetzt noch nicht genau angeschaut, wie dieses äh Versicherten-Stammdatenmanagement genau funktioniert. Innerhalb der TI hatte ich mir jetzt zuletzt mal das E-Rezept angeschaut und da ein paar Sachen kritisiert
Das sollte auch mit der EGK abgerufen werden können
was nicht ganz so sicher war ähm zum versicherten Standardmanagement, da kann ich keine Aussage treffen, ob das jetzt sicher ist oder nicht.
Okay, aber das ist sozusagen das Inviamen. Man hat ähm Computer in in der Arztpraxis. Diese Computer sind übers Netzwerk mit diesem Konnektor, was ein Stück,
Hardware äh ist, was müssten die das kaufen, wird das gestellt.
Das einen äh das das ist ein ganz ganz teures Premiumprodukt. Das ist ein so ein Router der kostet irgendwie mehrere tausend Euro und den muss sich der Arzt dann kaufen.
kriegt dafür aber auch Subventionen von den Krankenkassen und so. Aber ja, das ist im Endeffekt ein Produkt.
Mehrere tausend Euro für einen Rauter.
Ja, also ich weiß jetzt grad nicht so genau, was was der Neubeschaffungspreis ist. Ich weiß nur, dass der Austauschpreis so bei 2.300 Euro liegt. Ähm er hat das schon schon alles gut teuer. Und dann braucht man neben diesem Rauter auch noch einen
Zugang in die TI, das heißt, da fallen dann auch nochmal monatliche Kosten für an.
Also sprich, man braucht da einen Account in diesem Betriebssystem.
Genau richtig. Also.
Bekannt sein als als Praxis.
Das vielleicht an der Stelle mal ganz kurz erwähnenswert, dass alle Akteurinnen, die an diesem System teilnehmen, die sind eben identifiziert, also der Arzt hat eine Identität, du hast eine Identität.
Mhm.
Apotheke, die da dran teilnimmt, hat eine Identität.
Wenn du sagst, der Arzt meinst du die Praxis oder die einzelne Person?
Äh jede Person hat tatsächlich ähm so eine Smartcard, also,
Ärzte haben das Äquivalent, einer EGA, das nennt sich dann SMCB oder HBA, das ist der Heilberuf aus,
genau. Das ist das ist auch so eine Smartcard und damit sind die auch an diesem System authentifiziert und
identifiziert. Das heißt, wir haben da schon mal so Identitäten das Tablet und darauf basierend werden dann die ganzen Dienste innerhalb dieser telematischen Infrastruktur angeboten.
Gilt das auch für die ganzen Assistentinnen, die da arbeiten?
Also wie sich das dann konkret in der Arztpraxis gestaltet und wieder die Post-its an dem für die Passwörter am Bildschirm hängen, keine Ahnung, aber ähm.
Wahrscheinlich eher nicht, ne.
Eher nicht. Also es gibt diverse Rollen, die äh so eine Identität annehmen kann. Also es gibt äh
für alle möglichen unterschiedlichen Berufsgattungen irgendwie unterschiedliche Identitätstypen da drin, also es könnte sogar durchaus sein, dass theoretisch vorgesehen ist für so Assistentinnen oder so, da auch Identitäten irgendwie hinterlegt werden können.
Praxis ist das wahrscheinlich wie ein Computer, der irgendwo unentsperrt rumsteht und.
In der Praxis der Praxis sozusagen.
Ja genau.
Mhm. Okay, jetzt äh aber die einzige Anwendung, die wir jetzt sozusagen bisher abgerufen haben, ist ich identifiziere mich und die Praxis kann.
Damit abrechnen.
Kann damit abrechnen, kann mehr oder weniger auch in Anführungsstrichen beweisen, dass dass ich äh da war, wenn ich meine Karte nicht äh vergessen habe ähm und,
Bekommt dann die Praxis auch noch Informationen aus dieser Telematik Infrastruktur über mich,
zugestellt, also liegt irgendetwas über mich in dieser Telematik-Cloud vor, außer dass es mich gibt.
Da sind wir dann bei den weiteren Anwendungen innerhalb der TI unter anderem das E-Rezept. Da kann der Arzt dann für dich ein Rezept einstellen zum Beispiel.
Das ist so ein zentraler Datenspeicher,
und wenn der Arzt dann ein Rezept ausstellt, dann gestaltet sich das so. Der stellt eine Datenstruktur, da steht drin, was für ein Rezept du verschrieben bekommst. Da steht dann eine PZN drin. Da steht noch eine Dosierungsinformation drin und dann ähm
nimmt der Arzt oder halt die Software von dem Arzt dieses XML-Dokument, schickt das an diesen TE-Connect, an diesem Cluster-Router,
der stellt dann eine Signatur dadrunter mit Hilfe von dem Ausweis, den der Arzt hat, mit dieser SMCB und dann ist er eine Signatur drunter. Also sehr analog zudem ähm,
Verfahren wie ein normales Rezept ausgestellt wird, also gefüllt halt das Formular aus und setzt dann da seine Signatur drunter. Das heißt, man hat diesen Prozess ziemlich genau 1 zu1 digitalisiert mit einem Unterschied
wenn der Arzt dann dieses Rezept ausgestellt hat, dann legt ihr das aufs Faxgerät und überträgt das an den zentralen Datenspeicher. Natürlich nicht mitm Faxgerät, sondern mit ähm,
über diese Telematik-Infrastruktur und dann wird dieses,
Rezept in diesen zentralen Datenspeicher gespeichert, unverschlüsselt, also es wird Transport verschlüsselt und es wird dann auch verschlüsselt abgespeichert, aber im Grunde genommen liegt es unverschlüsselt an diesem zentralen Service vor,
und der zentrale Service antwortet nach dem Upload dieses Dokuments mit einer URL und diese URL nimmt der Arzt an und packt die für dich auf das Irrezamt und druckt das E-Rezept dann aus.
Als QR-Code.
Als 2D-Cott, ich weiß nicht, ob's mit ist, ich glaube oder so irgendein 2D-Code. So das ist eine der Anwendungen,
Dann gibt's noch die elektronische Patientenakte. Da kann der Arzt dann Dokumente für dich da reinstellen. Da gibt's ein bisschen mehr Krypto als beim E-Rezept.
Ich glaube, das würde jetzt zu weit finden, das genau zu erklären, wie er die Krypto aussieht.
Das müssen wir nicht machen, aber es gibt sozusagen also die existiert diese elektronischen Patientenakte.
Die existiert, die muss man aber sich anlegen lassen oder anlegen, damit du die tatsächlich hast. Also der Arzt wird jetzt nicht für dich da irgendwie irgendwelche Dokumente einfach hinterlegen können.
Okay, aber wenn ich eine, was muss ich dafür tun? Muss ich die muss ich.
Also normalerweise.
Oder?
Zum erstmal musst du krank.
Du du brauchst erstmal die PIN für deine Karte.
Ich nicht habe. Aha.
Das heißt, wahrscheinlich brauchst du da noch eine neue Karte, damit du für die Karte halt die Pin haben kannst. So damit kannst du dann in so einer App von deiner Krankenversicherung eine EPA anlegen und dann kann der Arzt da irgendwelche Dokumente reinstellen.
Es ist dir bekannt, dass das irgendwelche äh Krankenkassen auch tun.
Krankenkassen sind verpflichtet das anzubieten und die Ärzte sind auch verpflichtet äh das ebenfalls anzubieten. Wenn nicht drohen denen irgendwelche finanziellen Kürzungen.
Okay. Das heißt, wenn ich das jetzt haben wollen würde, würde ich mich mit meiner Krankenkasse.
Einen der Briefe von deiner Krankenkasse aufmachen, die sich wahrscheinlich seit Wochen,
Monaten bei dir Türen? Nee, das also tatsächlich, man denkt immer, man kriegt eine Rechnung von denen und dann sagen die, ey hier App hast du nicht gesehen. Ich glaube, wir haben auch die gleiche Krankenkasse, Tim und da wird das ein oder andere Mal, werden die dir schon gesagt haben, geh mal hier.
Dein Online-Postfach.
Genau, geh mal in deine äh sowieso App und äh lad das nochmal runter und wenn du da wenn ihr jetzt bei uns anrufst, äh dann.
Genau.
Alles voll geil.
Ähm auch noch andere Identifikationsverfahren, um diese Epa einzurichten. Teile davon wurden verboten, weil Video-Identität jetzt ja gehackt wurde.
der BFD auch untersagt, soweit ich weiß. Hm,
Aber die ähm der Hauptweg, wie das mal gedacht war oder auch gedacht ist, ist, du hast diese Edeka und hältst die PanfC an dein Telefon dran,
ähnlich wie der neue Personalausweis. Und dann kannst du dich halt damit gegenüber der Krankenkasse ausweisen und kannst dann auf deine Patientenakte zugreifen. Und der Arzt kann das auch, wenn du nämlich beim Arzt die Krankenkarte einsteckst in deren Kartenleser.
kann er da irgendwelche Dokumente reinstellen.
Aber ich bitte die auch selber mit meiner Krankenkassenkarte online abrufen.
Genau richtig. Im Endeffekt ist das einfach nur ein sehr kompliziertes Dropbox.
Aber ich brauche dafür einen Leser.
Nee, du brauchst einfach nur einen NFC-fähiges Telefon.
Ah, okay.
Was übrigens super verbreitet ist, weil die die Leute, die irgendwie so SSI,
äh immer die ganze Zeit fordern, die tun immer so als gäbe es irgendwie keine NFC fegen Telefon, aber keine Ahnung. Also so jedes Telefon, was ich irgendwie hatte, konnte NFC.
So
Versuche gerade zu gucken, ob meine.
Auch mal gucken jetzt.
Krankenkassenkarte, NFC kann.
Ja, ich glaube nämlich, meine kann das nicht, aber wissen tue ich's ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Sie hat auf jeden Fall einen Smartcard-Chip so damit.
Genau, damit kann sie auf jeden Fall in so ein Lesegerät äh und NFC ist ja dann eigentlich.
Darf ich mal sehen?
Ehrlich gesagt nicht hier.
Also hier steht jetzt so eine Krankenversichertennummer drauf.
Die liest jetzt nicht vor.
Okay, außer nicht. Mit der ist es dann nämlich möglich, einen oder war eigentlich mal vorgesehen, dass es damit möglich ist, einen E-Rezept abrufen zu können in der Apotheke.
Das haben wir äh haben wir natürlich auch behandelt. Das ist ja dein,
Dein erstes Thematikrelease auf CCC DE gewesen vor ein paar Wochen. Und ich glaube, da kann man jetzt zumindest schon mal den ersten kleinen technischen Exkurs machen, dass nämlich,
diese Karte, zumindest wenn man sie richtig ausliest, nämlich über den Chip,
durchaus ja äh also der Teil ist äh äh mit vertretbarem Aufwand so einfach wahrscheinlich nicht zu kopieren.
dass zumindest wenn sie pingeschützt wäre, ne also die die Präsenz dieser Karte, das also das sollte jetzt nicht wenn dieses Sicherheitssystem vernünftig funktioniert, sollte es nicht möglich sein den,
den Chip zu kopieren.
Das ist korrekt, ja.
Also meine Karte reagiert äh dich, obwohl ich da sowas WLAN-artiges äh so ein Symbol da oben drauf habe, aber auf NFC.
Ich habe auch ein WLAN-Symbol auf meiner meine WLAN weil jetzt habe ich's gefunden.
Das ist ja in so ein Apple-Telefon drangehalten, vielleicht musste das mal so ein null acht fuffzehn NFC Reader dran halten.
Ist auch eine nullacht1fünf hier, was.
Apple hat das doch total äh gestript, was so da die Apple macht doch nur Ende.
Kann ja äh kann ja auch meinen Personalausweis auslesen, also.
Ja, aber wenn du den Personalausweis an dein Telefon dran hältst und sagt, das Telefon von sich aus doch auch nicht. Ja, hallo, guten.
Nicht von sich aus. Ich habe so eine NFC-Auslese äh App gestartet und die hat,
darauf gewartet, dass die Karte sich meldet. Okay, also nochmal zurück. Gesundheitskarte,
soll quasi der Schlüssel sein zu dieser ganzen Telematik Infrastruktur sowohl für mich jetzt als Patienten als
auch für Praxen und im Zweifelsfall auch Apotheken und gegebenenfalls noch weitere Beteiligte in diesem ganzen System. Diese Patientenakte muss man aber
explizit einrichten lassen und man muss dann auch eine Gesundheitskarte mit einer PIN haben
die die Voraussetzung ist und dann ist sozusagen der Zugriff darauf, muss dann auch immer von mir auch in der Praxis dann quasi explizit freigegeben werden, also,
wenn er dann sozusagen sagte, ich würde aber jetzt gerne mal in ihre Patientenakte reinschauen, dann muss ich mit der Karte wählen, meine PIN irgendwo in so ein Feld ein äh tippen, weil sonst läuft da mal gar nichts.
Okay.
Ist korrekt, dass er auch prinzipiell sehr sinnvoll, dass wir da auf so Smartcard Security setzen und man diesen Zugriff explizit gewähren muss.
Das ist ja prinzipiell erstmal sehr sinnvoll, dass die GEMAtik dann sich dann auch eine Backdoor offen hält mit einem Schlüsselgenerierungsdienst, das ist dann nochmal was anderes.
Also ich meine so kryptografische Schlüssel, die generiert man ja eigentlich so idealerweise am besten so irgendwie offline. Manche Leute haben da so richtig obskure,
Zeremonien, wie sie irgendwie ihre private äh würfeln auf irgendwelchen Offline-Systemen so. Bei der Gamatik gibt es da einen ganz komfortablen Service,
die erzeugen nämlich für dich das Schlüsselmaterial, mit dem du dann die Inhalte in deiner elektronischen Patientenakte verschlüsselst.
Okay, gibt's jetzt außer dieser E-Rezept-Funktion, also der allgemein Identifikation, dem E-Rezept und dieser Patientenakte noch einen weiteren Dienst, den wir jetzt hier noch aufzählen müssen.
Die Gematik hat auch eine D-Mail äh gebaut, tatsächlich.
Yes, ich kann auch E-Mails damit schreiben. Du nicht, aber ernst. Ach so.
Du nicht, aber Ärzte. Die können sich dann äh da verschlüsselt, vertraulich äh Nachrichten zusenden lassen. Auch da keine Sorge, den Private Key generiert die Gamatik für dich und nicht du selber. Also.
Okay, das kannst.
Das alle alles sehr vertrauenswürdig, genau ja. Ähm.
Also wie findest du das so jetzt in seiner Gesamtheit, dieses äh System.
Was davon. Also im Speziellen.
Wie es erstmal designt ist im Großen und Ganzen.
Ach so. Also ich finde das insgesamt tatsächlich sehr sinnvoll, da so auf Security zu setzen und da auch irgendwie eine PIN zu verlangen. Finde ich irgendwie total recentival.
So, ich meine, das ist ja auch ein Sicherheitslevel, was wir irgendwie so von Finanztransaktionen kennen, so. Ich kann mit meiner Kreditkarte irgendwie so, keine Ahnung, so kleine Transaktionen irgendwie ohne Pin machen.
analog dazu wäre für mich irgendwie so, ich kann in der Apotheke irgendwie so ohne Pin I Rezept abrufen mit der EGK. Hm,
und für heiklere Dinge brauche ich dann irgendwie so eine PIN. Ähm,
Wenn wir dann weitergucken, so äh in die Arztpraxis reinschauen, finde ich das Konzept, dass man da irgendwie so einen stehen hat, auch wenn er jetzt irgendwie absurd teuer ist. Ähm auch total sinnvoll, denn der Arzt kann damit coole Sachen machen. Der kann nämlich,
Signatur unter dein Rezept runterstellen und das ist ziemlich praktisch, denn der kann das da offline machen
dass er das Rezept dann hinterher hochlädt ist doof und kacke, das
man irgendwie anders bauen, aber der kann das, was man prinzipiell offline dezentral machen. Das heißt, wir haben da eine ziemlich hohe Verfügbarkeit und das ist auch privacymäßig total nice, weil das halt erstmal prinzipiell nicht die Arztpraxis verlassen muss. Ähm
Auch dass man irgendwie so eine Patientenakte hat, finde ich total sinnvoll. Für dich auch.
Ja, also ich sehe da auf jeden Fall ein News Case drin, hm ob die jetzt in der aktuellen Ausgestaltung medizinisch so sinnvoll ist, also,
habe mit ein paar Medizinern gesprochen, die finden das Ding irgendwie nicht so pralle, die sind generell mit dem Gesamtsystem irgendwie ein bisschen ja eher unglücklich, weil das halt sehr teuer und kompliziert ist und so weiter.
Aber so insgesamt ähm,
voll dafür, so dass wir halt das Gesundheitswesen digitalisieren. Wichtig ist halt ähm, dass wir das Ganze sicher gestalten und dass wir da den Patienten, den Patientinnen, die Schlüssel in ihre Hand drücken.
und das halt nicht die Thematik machen lassen
die dann ja keine Ahnung also da gibt's dann halt auch so Startups die dann irgendwie so mit Gesundheit mit so medizinischen Daten irgendwie Geld verdienen wollen oder da irgendwie Forschung dran treiben wollen und,
Ja, also ich möchte eigentlich gerne selber drüber entscheiden können, wer da meine Daten zu sehen bekommt und damit ich,
Da die Kontrolle über meine Daten habe, ist halt sehr wichtig, dass ich auch die Schlüssel äh dazu in der Hand halte.
Da sollten wir vielleicht nochmal aufdröseln. Also wenn ich mir jetzt diese Gesundheitskarte mit PIN hole und sage hier hör mal, legt mir meine Gesundheits äh.
Eine Akte an. Mhm.
Akte an. Genau, also eine.
Du bist auch wieder im im Wald der der Abkürzung natürlich, ne? Wenn das also eine Gamatik baut, eine Telematik. Allein das und dann hast du eine EGK.
Und eine Ehepaar, die nicht zu verwechseln ist.
Ist nicht gleich Ehepaar.
Kann ich schon verstehen, dass die Ärzte da sagen so, Hustensaft? Hustensaftrezept, verdammt!
Na ja, okay, also wir haben,
Ich gehe da jetzt mal ganz ähm einfach ran und und und denkt, das ist das das das Tollste für mich so. Ich will so eine Patientenakte haben, so eine elektronische und ich möchte gerne, dass dann wenn ich zum Arzt renne und der checkt mich dann so durch,
Einmal gucken,
funktioniert da alles noch, dann wäre ja sozusagen dieses Ergebnis, die Summe aller Laborergebnisse und meine Werte und der Befund und so weiter, das könnte dann da alles reingeschrieben werden.
Dann könnte man da reinschreiben der Tim, der hat jetzt noch TÜV, bis, keine Ahnung, Dezember.
Genau und ist das dann irgendwo verschlüsselt oder ist das nur auf dem Weg verschlüsselt?
Es ist ganz kompliziert verschlüsselt und das das das äh meiner Meinung nach absichtlich so, dass das äh schwierig und kompliziert zu verstehen ist, was eigentlich passiert. Ähm das Ganze funktioniert so,
und zwar bei der Einrichtung deiner Akte wird einen Aktenschlüssel erzeugt. Den würfelst du tatsächlich selber,
dann ja, den also deine App würfelt den halt selber.
Ah da ist eine App mit im Spiel.
Da brauchst du dann einrichten, wie gesagt, die EGK mit PIN oder irgendwie ein anderes identifizierungsverfahren gibt's, glaube ich, auch irgendwie zwei Krankenkassen, die da das mit dem neuen Personalausweis, kurz Emper,
anbieten. Aber am Ende des Tages würfelst du deinen Aktenschlüssel. So. Mit dieser Aktenschlüssel wird dann verschlüsselt mit,
Schlüsselmaterial, was von der Gamatik kommt und zwar aus dem Schlüsselgenerierungsdienst. Was da passiert ist, du meldest dich mit der EGK an, an diesem Schlüsselgenerierungsdienst,
und sagst ihm, ey du, gib mir mal einen Schlüssel, gib mir mal ein Passwort.
Machst du nicht nur an einem, sondern an zwei, weil die GEMAtik selber festgestellt hat, dass es irgendwie ein blödes Verfahren ist, dass da aus so einem zentralen System Passwort oder ein Schlüssel halt rausfällt. Deswegen hat sich die Thematik gedacht, okay
Nummer zwei und organisatorisch voneinander getrennt, dann ist das ja sicher. Ist ja unwahrscheinlich, dass irgendwie beide böseartig sind.
Das heißt, du hast dann Schlüssel für deine Akt und verschlüsselst es mit der Antwort aus dem SGD eins, also Schlüsselgenerierungsdienst 1 und verschlüsselst das nochmal, das Ergebnis mit der Antwort aus dem Schlüsselgenerierungsdienst zwei.
Das Ergebnis liegst du dann neben deiner elektronische Patientenakte ab und,
Hast du denn da deinen verschlüsselten Aktenschlüssel drin liegen, an denen du auch wieder drankommst, indem du wieder zu SGD 1 und SGD zwei gehst und dir die Schlüssel von heute wiederholst und das Endschlüssel und so weiter, dann hast du einen Aktenschlüssel,
Haben wir noch keine Dokumente verschlüsselt, um Dokumente zu verschlüsseln brauchen wir einen Dokumentenschlüssel.
Dieser Dokumentenschlüssel, den würfelst du auch oder der Arzt würfelt, den selber. Dieser Dokumentenschlüssel wird dann mit dem Aktenschlüssel, den wir neben die Eper gelegt haben und unsicher verschlüsselt haben, verschlüsselt,
verschlüsselten Dokumentenschlüssel. Und um das Ganze jetzt nochmal von der Rückseite äh aufzudröseln, wenn du jetzt auf ein Dokument zugreifen möchtest, sieht das so aus.
du lädst dir das Dokument runter an dem Dokument steht der verschlüsselte Dokumentenschlüssel,
dann gehst du einmal in SGD eins, SGD2 und entschlüsselst damit deinen Aktenschlüssel, mit dem Aktenschlüssel entschlüsselst, den Dokumentenschlüssel, mit dem Dokumentenschlüssel, entschlüsselst du das Dokument und dann hältst du das Dokument in der Hand.
Das Problem an der ganzen Sache ist, ist der SG die eins und SGD zwei, also der Schlüsselgenerierungsdienst, denn wer diese beiden Instanzen kontrolliert, kann alle Dokumente in der elektronischen Patientakte entschlüsseln.
Also eigentlich, wenn man äh wenn du dir schon so ein komplexes hier brauchst, nur einen Schlüssel und da und sonst was anhörst, ne, dann weißt du eigentlich in der Regel schon,
Kann nicht sicher sein, weil die Lösung ist ja sehr viel einfacher. Du hast einfach einen Schuss. Du hast ja einen, du hast ja eine Smart Card, warum verschlüsselt du nicht damit?
Ja richtig, das ist ja eigentlich total naheliegend. Das wäre auch viel einfacher.
Und wenn immer, immer wenn solche Sprünge gemacht werden, weißt du schon, ne, also für für jemanden, der sich mit IT-Sicherheit und Verschlüsselung auskennt, merkst du, oh, oh, oh, hier wird Augenwischerei betrieben, hier will jemand echt ganz gut verstecken, dass er grade Mist macht?
während jemand, der keine Ahnung davon hat, denkt so, boah.
Das aber echt.
Dreimal verschlüsselt,
so ne, also dreimal verschlüsselst du halt nicht nur, wenn wenn einmal nicht reicht, aber dann reicht halt auch dreimal nicht. Ähm.
Man muss auch an der Stelle noch ein bisschen entkräften, äh was dieser äh es gibt ja zwei Schlüsselgenerierungsdienste in der Hoffnung, dass es halt durch eine organisatorische Trennung das halt nicht beide bösartig sind so. Jetzt kannst du aber wahrscheinlich die Anzahl
HSM, also so Hardware Security Modelhersteller, so im Prinzip Firmen, die solche Schlüssel.
Niedriger einstelliger Bereich.
Ja, ich würde vermutlich das irgendwo so auf eins schätzen so. Das heißt, dass er tatsächlich am Ende des Tages auch zwei unterschiedliche Implementationen laufen, unklar, weiß ich nicht. Und,
Viel wichtiger die äh die am Ende des Tages dahinter steht, denn irgendjemand hat dir ja auch die EGK ausgestellt,
mit der du dich dann an der am SGD1 und SGD2 anmeldest. Und dieser jemand kann auch einfach wieder eine ausstellen, also,
unterstelle ich jetzt grade bösartig, da stehen bestimmt organisatorische Prozesse hinter, aber am Ende des Tages haben wir damit einen Singlepoint of Failia,
was die.
Was die die signierenden, die äh eG äh EGKs ausstellen können. So, jetzt sind wir aber, glaube ich, ein bisschen, Tim, du wolltest nicht so tief ins Detail, aber du hast natürlich dann ins Detail gefragt. Jetzt musst du.
Okay, du hast eine Epa.
Genau, also ich meine, es ist ja ich vielleicht ist es jetzt auch nur meine Perspektive, aber das ist so ein bisschen auch meine Wahrnehmung, wenn man so mit anderen Leuten spricht von dieser ganzen digitalen Realität,
liest man viel, immer, wenn irgendwas schief geht so, aber dass die da ist und dass man an dir teilnehmen kann, das ist, glaube ich, den wenigsten bewusst, geschweige denn was man tun muss, um daran teilnehmen zu können.
Ja, das sehen wir auch beim Personalausweis.
Genau, ne, da da liegt einfach äh so Infrastruktur rum und die wird dann auch äh finanziert und aufgebaut, aber ich habe immer so ein bisschen die Frage, ob sie dann halt auch wirklich benutzt wird.
Ist ja gerade schon gesagt. Ich glaube so bei den Ärztinnen und Ärzten ist das jetzt nicht so sehr beliebt. Diese GEMAtik, ne, die stellen hohe Rechnungen einmalig.
Nicht nicht die Thematik, aber dann die Hersteller, die.
Oder die Hersteller genau das System, ja die TI, die Telematik-Infrastruktur ist nicht so beliebt, weil die Stellen hohe einmalige Rechnung und hohe monatliche Rechnungen.
Und natürlich ist beträgt sage ich mal der der Akzeptanz eines solchen Systemes,
trägt natürlich primär auch bei, ob die Ärztinnen und Ärzte,
das gut finden. Und ich kann jetzt so sagen als CCC kriegen wir schon sehr, sehr regelmäßig so,
handgeschriebene Briefe,
die man kaum lesen kann, der weiß das schon wieder ah Ärztin oder so, ne, die dann irgendwie sich beklagen und sagen, hier die wollen immer mehr Geld von mir haben, die sind doof,
überhaupt sicher, könnt ihr die nicht kaputt machen? Wir sind gezwungen die zu nutzen, finden wir alles nicht gut.
Ob die das gut finden oder nicht, also du hast es schon äh leicht durchklingen lassen. Das ist am Ende des Tages egal. Auch ob du das gut oder nicht gut findest, weil das E-Rezept kommt zwangsweise. So, da gibt's.
E-Rezept, äh EPA die haben halt keine Wahl und Leute, die keine Wahl haben, äh äh sind nur häufiger unglücklich, aber,
müssen wir natürlich mal einen Aspekt äh würdigen,
Die ganze TI ist wahrscheinlich um einiges sauberer, sicherer und äh besser durchdacht,
als der Rest, der in so einer Arztpraxis so rumsteht. Ne also ob das jetzt
sieben Jahre alte äh hochmoderne Röntgengerät mit einer SMB 1 Dateienfreigabe ist oder irgendeine komische Abrechnungssoftware, die da noch von einer Drittanbieterin hingestellt wurde oder der Team Viewer Fernzugriff von dem
IT-Fuzzi um die Ecke, der sich darum kümmert, wenn der Drucker nicht funktioniert, ne? Da findest du schon einen relativ großen Zoo,
ähm den zu bändigen oder mit dem zu leben, ist ja auch eine oder eine Herausforderung für die,
TI
Richtig und dem ist man mit diesem TI-Konnektor, wie ich finde, durchaus gelungen begegnet.
Bevor wir auf den äh Connector die Probleme äh damit kommen, sorry, ähm was natürlich auch immer so ein bisschen im Raum steht, ist, wer hat was davon?
Ja, weil das Ganze klingt jetzt erstmal alles so ein bisschen wie wie wie Selbstzweck, ne so hat man was von der elektronischen Patientenakte haben Ärzte was davon
haben äh Patienten was davon, das ist ja das letzten Endes das Argument, was ja zählen äh muss.
Also du kannst in die bis zu 25 Megabyte große Dokumente reinladen. Das heißt, wenn du schon mal irgendwie so ein, weiß nicht, so ein CT oder.
Relativ kleines MRT.
Ja. Fünf2und Megabyte.
Ein grob pixeliges MRT von deinem kleinen Zeh.
Kein Röntgenbild rein irgendwie.
Kommt halt drauf an, wie alt die Maschine ist, ne. Also ich meine, Apple hat ja mit einem Imagecode schon eigentlich ganz gute Kompression vorgeführt so, aber,
Also der praktische Nutzen, weiß ich nicht, kann ich nicht einschätzen. Also,
Erstmal sind die Dateien natürlich relativ klein, so die man da reinpacken kann und am Ende des Tages ist es halt einfach nur ein loses Sammelsurium an Dateien, du hast nicht mal soweit ich weiß nicht mal eine Ordnerstruktur da drinne. Das heißt,
das am Ende des Tages ist die EPA eine super komplizierte Schnittstelle, wo halt ähm.
Irgendwelche Files drin stehen, indem man so rumblättern kann.
Ja richtig, also es sind die die Dateien sind halt nicht irgendwie wohl strukturiert oder so. Das heißt, du kannst dann da auch schön irgendwelche Word-Dokumente mit Makros drinnen oder so da reinschmeißen.
mit entsprechend fatalen Folgen für die Computersysteme so eine Arztpraxis halt alles irgendwie nicht so prickelnd.
Also, was sozusagen diese Gematik TI nicht ist, ist ein Ort, wo sozusagen sich meine Gesundheit drin wiederspiegelt. Weil so kennt man das ja vom Smartphone so, da hat man äh also zumindest vom iPhone so eine.
Sowohl strukturiert irgendwie drin stehen kannst.
Genau, da sind so alle Werte drin und wenn irgendeine App.
Lassen, so wie sich dein Körpergewicht.
Und wenn irgendeine App
äh sagen wir mal Interesse an meiner Größe oder an meinem Gewicht hat, dann muss sie fragen, darf ich darauf zugreifen und dann ist es aber auch wirklich nur genau dieses eine Ding äh worauf man zugreift und wenn irgendwas schreiben möchte, weil,
Hallo, ich bin eine Waage, ich wiege dein Gewicht, ich würde es dir gerne in deine Datenbank rein äh kippen, dann kann man das ja auch machen und dann hat man da sozusagen so einen Storage, der eben
den eigenen Gesundheitszustand oder den eigenen Körper gesamt, was auch immer Zustand äh reflektiert. Aber das ist nicht das, was eine,
Patientenakte in dieser Gamatik Infrastruktur macht, sondern es ist im Prinzip so eine Art Dropbox, die zu klein geraten ist.
Richtig. Und am Ende des Tages muss man auch sagen, dass da so Anforderungen, Apple,
besser realisiert hat. Du hast es ja grad schon dargestellt, so dass man halt sehr selektiv entscheiden kann, was jetzt eigentlich gerade freigegeben wird.
Es ist auch möglich, an die Dateien, die in der EPA drinne liegen, dranzuschreiben, wer da jetzt irgendwie drauf zugreifen kann oder nicht.
Das ist schon möglich. Man kann da irgendwie äh durchaus auch so ACLs, also Zugriffsberechtigungen drauf erteilen und das irgendwie sehr fein Granular einstellen.
aber am Ende des Tages hältst du halt nicht die Schlüssel zu deinen Patientendaten in der Hand, von daher ist das halt eh alles schall und Rauch.
Und ich kann vor allem nicht jetzt irgend so eine Gesundheitsapp laden, über die wir ja auch schon äh gesprochen.
Da arbeiten sie grade dran, dass wenn diese Digas, diese digitalen Gesundheitsanwendungen auch mit in die äh EPA, also in die elektronische Patientenakte mit rein integrieren.
Ja gut, aber auch die müsste dann sozusagen durch irgendeinen Pfeil Storage sozusagen durchbrowsen und hat nicht wirklich so eine Datenbank auf die sie granular zugreifen kann, sondern ist nur so, darf ich mir dieses Dokument.
Ja genau und dann ist es dann.
Versuchen, dieses Wort Dokument zu pasen.
Ach das ist doch alles irgendwie nix.
Es gibt äh ganz es gibt,
Standards dafür, wie man diese Gesundheitsdaten irgendwie sinnvoll entkurdiert. Es gibt Pfeile dafür, das sind die Fast Healthcare Intrability, Resources. Ich glaube, ich hab's richtig.
Das ist das, was Apple zum Beispiel verwendet, wenn ich.
Ich weiß es nicht. Ähm an der Stelle, wie Apple das inkludiert, aber es gibt Verfahren, diese medizinischen Daten maschinen lesbar zu entkurdieren.
Das wird aber in der Epa nicht vorgeschrieben. Wäre aber sehr wünschenswert, um halt diesen Problem äh ich lade da jetzt irgendwie eine myware in meine Epa hoch äh zu umfahren.
ist aber auf der anderen Seite natürlich auch gefährlich, denn sobald wir da irgendwelche maschinen lesbaren Gesundheitsdaten
drinne stehen haben, dann kommen natürlich auch die Datengeier, ne.
Klar. Gut, lassen wir das mal äh raus und kommen dann mal so zu dem äh Kern der äh jüngsten Aktivitäten,
ähm dieser Connector, dieses Stück teurer Hardware, was jetzt jede Arztpraxis äh braucht. Die ist äh seit wann aufm Markt?
Zweitausendsiebzehn.
Und.
Ja, die läuft so langsam ab
die äh die Gematik hat da einen für die Hersteller sellukratives Geschäftsmodell entwickelt und zwar haben diese Geräte einfach falsch Datum, so klassische geplante Obsolistenz, wenn man so möchte.
Das heißt, die laufen ab. Die laufen natürlich nicht alle gleichzeitig an einem Tag ab, sondern die laufen fünf Jahre nach Produktionsdatum ab. Die wurden natürlich nicht alle irgendwie an einem Tag verkauft und um in den Praxen installiert. Aber die wurden so nach 2tausendsiebzehn halt,
in den Praxen dann mit immer zunehmenden Zwang halt installiert.
Was heißt, die laufen äh ab. Da haben so ein Selbstzündungsmechanismus und sprengen sich dann in die Luft oder äh zersetzen sich.
Na du musst dir das so ein bisschen so wie so ein Mindesthaltbarkeitsdatum, dein Scherz. Also die haben äh
ein Zertifikat und so Zertifikate haben einen Ablaufsdatum und das ist nicht wie bei deinem Kühlschrank, wo du so nochmal irgendwie dran riechst und schmeckst, ob man das vielleicht doch noch irgendwie
sondern der Computer sagt dann nein
Mein Computer nein sagt, dann ist blöd. So Zertifikate haben grundsätzlich alle irgendwie so ein Ablaufdatum. Das ergibt auch total Sinn.
in Browsern ergibt das total Sinn, weil so Zertifikate zurückzuziehen irgendwie so ein eher medium geil gelöstes Problem ist,
Aber dafür haben wir so eigentlich schon seit Ewigkeiten Mechanismen solche Zertifikate automatisch zu verlängern.
So, jeder, der schon mal irgendwie benutzt hat, der kennt das, der weiß, dass die Zertifikate nur 90 Tage haltbar sind und dann gibt's da so dieses Akneverfahren, um das automatisch zu verlängern, dieses Zertifikat.
aber,
hat das halt nicht spezifiert oder halt nicht vorgeschrieben für diese Konnektoren. Das heißt, die Zertifikate auf diesen Konnektoren haben die Laufzeit von fünf Jahren und wenn die rum ist, dann muss der Konnektor ausgetauscht werden.
so die Gamatik.
Und das sind äh,
er zwei Bite ne, die die das Ding oder je nachdem wie welcher Kodierung sogar noch weniger die die dann definieren.
Das Gerät ist jetzt Schrott.
Dieses Gerät wird jetzt nicht mehr akzeptiert. Ja, also das das Schlüsselpaar, was das Gerät hat, das Zertifikat, mit dem es sich dann an der TI anmeldet und sagt, hallo, ich bin ein Konnektor und ich ich darf das,
Das ist dann abgelaufen und dann sagt die Infrastruktur am anderen Ende, ja Pech gehabt.
Pech gehabt, genau. Der TE-Connector ist einen VPN-Router, wenn man so möchte und er meldet sich per an dieser zentralen TI-Infrastruktur an.
Also IP-Sec verschlüsseltes.
VPN, genau, ja. So und dafür werden diese Zertifikate benötigt und wenn die dann abgelaufen sind, dann sagt die Gegenstände nope.
So und üblicherweise, also dessen Zertifikat ausläuft jetzt auch also bei,
Lets and Creak, hast gerade gesagt, dann holst dir einfach ein neues, dafür musst du einmal wieder mit dem Verfahren beweisen.
Dass du Kontrolle über die dummen genau.
Immer noch die Domain kontrollierst ähm bei äh bei anderen Verfahren würde man sich üblicherweise einfach darum kümmern, solange,
Der existierende Kanal, man dem noch vertraut, dass man halt entweder ein neues Zertifikat austeilt oder,
das Alte in seiner Gültigkeit verlängert,
Ja und sagt hier übrigens, hier ist ein neusigniertes Zertifikat. Ich habe deine die Gültigkeit deines Keepers, ähm um was weiß ich, um Jahr inkommentiert oder von mir aus auch nur um könnte man ja sogar monatlich machen.
du kannst machen wenn du einen Prozess hast, kannst du das so oft machen, wie du möchtest und dann würde,
kürzer auch sogar sinnvoller sein, ne? Weil der Umkehrschluss ist ja auch, wenn ein ein,
zwei Jahre alten Konnektor hast, der funktioniert noch drei Jahre, vorausgesetzt du hast noch einen halbe Ruferausweis, womit du den dann irgendwie.
Den kann man aber separat austauschen.
Nur mal kurz, müssen wir mal kurz mal nochmal klar machen, was worüber wir jetzt hier eigentlich gerade reden. Also da ist so ein Stück Hardware. Die ist vielleicht 5 Jahre alt,
Aber ist nicht so, dass die jetzt nicht mehr up to date wäre oder so. Die tut alles, was sie äh tun muss.
Die war auch schon bei Verkauf nicht mehr also das ist halt wirklich absolut garstige garstige Hardware, die die Herstelle.
Ja, okay, gut. Lass es mich anders formulieren. Es gäbe vielleicht gute Gründe äh dieser Hardware als solche auch mal äh zu modernisieren und
neue Geräte herzustellen, was sicherlich auch getan wird, aber es ist jetzt auch nicht so, dass nur weil jetzt dieses voreingestellte Zertifikat auf einmal seinen Ablaufdatum erreicht, dass das Gerät einen Tag später nicht mit einer vergleichbaren äh Performan
wie ein Tag vorher immer noch seine Tätigkeit aufnehmen kann. Und jetzt sollen sozusagen,
Hundert30tausend von bereits in Arztpraxen in Deutschland installierte Konjunkturen oder Apotheken, wo auch immer das äh steht, soll einfach das gesamte Gerät, was eigentlich noch im Prinzip das,
was wir äh von ihm möchten, soll komplett ersetzt werden für.
Kannst du ausrechnen.
Euro äh.
Summe kostet, ne?
Nur weil da so ein Bit umgefallen ist, was man.
Ist ja nicht umgefallen. Das.
Na ja, aber,
das Bit, was sagt, ich funktioniere noch so, ja. Das ist jetzt sozusagen umgefallen, also ansonsten hat sich dann aber erstmal gar nichts dran geändert. Man soll also sozusagen jetzt nochmal zweitausenddreihundert Euro oder was auch immer dann die,
Vorgang insgesamt kostet, weil da muss ja nochmal Firmen beauftragt werden und so weiter.
Lustige Anekdote eigentlich wollte die Combo Group medical für den Austausch, wenn ich richtig informiert bin, 2700 Euro haben,
Dann hat das Bundesschiedsgericht oder so, es wurde auf jeden Fall beschlossen, dass dann für den Austausch 2300 Euro erstattet werden den Ärzten,
Und dann hat die großzügigerweise zufällig die Kosten reduziert auf 2300 Euro.
Das heißt, es bezahlt dann alles wer.
Bier, die versicherten.
Okay, aber nicht die Praxen. Immerhin. Aber dieses Geld muss dann bezahlt werden für neue Hardware, die nicht unbedingt erforderlich wäre.
Richtig, die Hardware ist noch gut. Das heißt, wir produzieren einen riesengroßen Müllberg an Hardware, die eigentlich noch in Ordnung ist.
Und natürlich auch entsprechenden Aufwand in den Arztpraxen und Dinge müssen äh geändert werden. Immer wenn sich was ändert, dann geht auch mal was schief.
Die Folgekosten werden wahrscheinlich noch sehr viel höher sein als die drei, 400 Millionen, die da gerade im Raum stehen,
so ein Austausch offline so eine Praxis, kurzzeitig zumindest. Du hast es richtig gesagt, da können auch mal Sachen irgendwie bei schiefgehen und so. Ähm das heißt, die Folgekosten davon werden wahrscheinlich noch sehr viel höher sein für das gesamte Gesundheitssystem.
Welche Architektonischen Gründe sprechen, denn dagegen,
einfach, aktualisierte Zertifikate auszustellen. Was also wenn man jetzt der Gamatik sagt, hey,
Stellt doch einfach, also zwei Möglichkeiten stellt komplett neue Zertifikate aus und stellt dieses keep here zu über den über den Trusted Channel, den ihr ja habt,
oder, also mit anderen Worten, ne, ich gebe dir einfach ein neues Zertifikat, ein komplett neues mit einem neuen private ja oder noch sinnvoller,
Ich kenne ja, ich habe dir ja schon mal deinen äh dein Zertifikat beglaubigt, das ist ja signiert von einer CA und jetzt nehme ich das aus der Tasche.
Und,
hole mir jetzt zum Beispiel, mache mir wieder den äh CSR, den ist der tiffige Signing Request. Und jetzt signiere ich dir den einfach mit einem Jahr längerer Laufzeit. Ich weiß zufällig, dass das geht,
letztes Jahr in einem Projekt mit der Situation konfrontiert war, dass wir ein Gerät gebaut haben, was eine Laufzeit haben sollte, die sagen wir mal
die übers also wo wir nicht wussten, ob er das Gerät kaputtgeht oder die Zertifikate ablaufen.
Und wo wir dann wussten, potenziell werden wir also werden wir entweder die,
OP am offenen Herzen machen müssen, im Ding neue Zertifikate auszustellen oder wir nehmen den einfachen Weg für den Fall, dass es keinen
ähm Hinweis auf Kompromittierung des Schlüsselmaterials gibt,
wir die existierenden Zertifikate einfach verlängern. Wenn man, solange wir es im Dateisystem hat, gibt's X Formate, sagen wir einfach mal, ne, du nimmst, du generierst einfach ein neues CRT-Film. Du brauchst nur den CSR und.
Nicht mehr den CSR. Musst einfach nur Open SSA ein bisschen verbiegen, dann kannst du für einen beliebigen Publiqu.
Auch gebaut, weil aber ne, du du kannst einfach sagen, okay, wir machen wir stellen dir ein neues Zertifikat aus, diesmal mit einem Jahr längerer Laufzeit. Warum machen die das nicht? Was ist die Begründung, die die anführen, warum sie das nicht.
Ja. Also du hast korrekt dargestellt. Man kann so ein Zertifikat ausstellen, auch wenn man nur den Publicy hat. Man braucht dafür nicht mehr den CSR. Ähm
Das heißt, das ist eigentlich kein Problem. Was die Hersteller, die Gematik jetzt hier an dieser Stelle anführen, ist, na ja, also dieses Zertifikat und dieser Privaty, die liegen ja nicht auf dem Dateisystem, sondern wir haben da so eine Smartcard drin verbaut. Diese Smartcard, über die wir da sprechen, die nennt sich GSM
total super handlicher Name. Das davon stecken so zwei oder drei Stück in dem Konnektor.
Gesundheits-SMC-Karte, oder? Für die.
Weiß nicht, wofür die. Also K steht für Connector. Das.
Geräte spezifische Sicherheitsmodulkarte Connector.
Großartiger Name, fast fast so gut wie qualifizierte elektronische Signatur. Ähm ja, also dieser private lebt auf dieser Smartcard und der kommt da so auch erst mal nicht raus. Das.
Und nicht um das.
Genau, das ist ja auch nicht notwendig, aber eher der andere. Richtig, das ist.
Sogar eher der Anlass das ist das Zertifikat verlängern kann, weil ich weiß der ist sicher aufgehoben.
Könnte man doch einfach dieses Mark rausziehen und eine andere reinstecken.
Langsam, langsam, langsam. Jetzt jetzt muss ich dich mal einbremsen äh und zwar ähm man kann nicht einfach so Daten auf dieses Smartkarte schreiben.
das da muss man gegenüber der Karte ausgewiesen sein, angemeldet sein und so weiter und so fort. Das funktioniert, wenn du zum Beispiel deine Kreditkarte in Bankautomaten steckst, dann kann die Bank einen sicheren Kanal bis in die Smartcard in irgendeinem
Bankautomaten herstellen und kann die Software in deiner updaten dir neue Zertifikate ausstellen, dies das.
Das hat man bei der TI leider nicht gebaut. Also der Hersteller kann nicht einen vertrauenswürdigen Kanal bis in die Smartcard aufbauen. Das wäre eigentlich eine industrieüblicher Ansatz, wie man äh sowas heutzutage eigentlich auch schon damals äh baut und spezifiziert.
Will heißen, der kann zwar an das Keep her von mir aus ein neues Zertifikat senden. Er kann aber nicht sicherstellen, dass nicht unterwegs der oder der Konnektor selber,
mit abfängt und kann deswegen auch nicht verhindern, dass jemand, der vielleicht die Karte irgendwo ausgebaut hat, sich,
neuen Schlüsse geben lässt, weil du auf der anderen Seite nicht sicherstellen kannst, dass du wirklich nur mit der Karte redest und dich gegenüber der Karte authentifizierst.
Also,
Wir schicken da keine private durch die Gegend. Das schon mal wichtig. Wir wir schicken nur Zertifikate, das sind öffentliche Informationen. Die kann man frei durch die Gegend,
kommunizieren ist kein Problem durch die Gegend. Wir machen da nichts mit dem private. Der bleibt auf der Smartcard. So das Problem ist
Wir haben jetzt für diesen private ein neues Zertifikat. Wie kriegen wir dieses Zertifikat in diesen Konnektor rein? Das ist die spannende Frage.
die Hersteller könnte,
dafür hatte das passende ähm Schlüsselmaterial, gibt da so damit könnte der Hersteller die Smartkarte frisch beschreiben und da das neue Zertifikat reinschreiben. Das wäre eine Möglichkeit.
Aber dazu braucht man unmittelbaren Gerät Zugriff.
Na ja, der Hersteller könnte das mit einem Update. Ähm aber Oma grade ganz kurz die Argumentationsweise der Hersteller zusammenzufassen ist, wir haben da,
eine drinne und das Zertifikat ist auf dieser Smartcard. Die Smartcard ist fest verbaut und die können wir nicht austauschen und wir können das Zertifikat dadrauf nicht aktualisieren. So, das ist die Argumentation, der herrsch.
Was heißt fest verbaut?
Also,
die Hersteller haben das, die Hersteller haben das so lange fest verbaut, bezeichnet bis CT halt das einmal aufgeschraubt hat und die rausgenommen, wieder reingesteckt hat und gezeigt hat. Hier Leute geht im.
Fest verbaut, heißt einfach nur ab Werk reingesteckt. Aber kann man auch wieder rausstecken.
Naja, ist ja sicher versiegelt, ne? Also muss ja ein Siegel brechen, um an die.
Oh.
Dann darfst du ihn noch nicht mehr betreiben, wenn das Siegel gebrochen ist. So, aber die Argumentationslinie ist, wir haben da dieses Smartcard drinnen und da kann man nichts machen, ist doof. Und man kann die Smart Card nicht
austauschen, ist die Argumentationslinie der Hersteller. Und deswegen haben wir einen Patch gebaut, der funktioniert.
Moment, warum kann man sie nicht austauschen?
Das ist eine längere Geschichte und.
Kann man sie nicht austauschen oder sagen sie nur, man könnte sie nicht austauschen.
Man kann sie austauschen, das geht. Es ist die Frage, mit welchem Aufwand und mit welchem Verfahren man sie austauscht. Dazu muss ich ein bisschen weiter ausholen.
In diesem Connector befindet sich eine Festplatte.
ob wir's lieben. Da ist das System drauf äh von diesem Konnektor für die unterschiedlichen Anwendungen und so weiter,
und in dem Konnektor befindet sich auch ein sicherer Speicher. Das ist ein verschlüsseltes Dateisystem
und um an dieses äh verschlüsselte Dateisystem dranzukommen, braucht man ebenfalls dieses,
Und da haben wir eine Verknüpfung von dem äh Dateisystem,
und dieser Smartcard. Wenn ich jetzt einfach die Smartcard austausche, dann komme ich nicht mehr in den verschlüsselten Speicher ran, weil,
Austausch der Karte passen die Schlüssel nicht mehr zu den Schlüsseln, die auf der das liegen. Aber,
Wir haben ja zwei oder drei Slots in so einem Connector. Das heißt, zum Hochfahren, rund um dieses Dateisystem zu entschlüsseln, brauche ich eine Karte,
Das heißt, die Originale GSMCK, die kann einfach stecken bleiben, eine, damit wir die Kiste weiterhin hochfahren können,
Da haben wir noch zwei Slots und da können wir dann irgendwie moderne Karten reinstecken, die von mir aus auch längere Schlüssellängen unterstützen und so weiter und so fort und die längere Zertifikate haben.
Das haben alle Konnektoren, diese Slots.
Also ähm ich habe jetzt ein Sekunde eine Kiste von Sekunde aufgemacht, eine Kiste von CGM. Die beiden zusammen haben deutlich über die Hälfte des Marktanteils.
und bei denen ist das der Fall, die haben drei SIM-Karten-Slots. Ich weiß nicht, ob von der Gammatik vorgeschrieben ist, dass sie drei Stück haben müssen, aber dort würde das zumindest gehen
und gerade die CGM stellt sich sehr auf und sagt, nee, das kann man nicht tauschen, wir müssen die Konnektoren austauschen.
Es könnte also jetzt welche Gründe könnten die denn haben? Also es kommt mir bei wie viel 1hundert.000 Konnektoren da draußen.
Hundert30tausend.
Natürlich auch ein bisschen also wer jetzt schon krass oder wer schon viel Aufwand wenn jetzt über eine qualifizierte Person hinkommen muss, das Siegel bricht ja,
Die Garantie von dem Schrottkonnektor, der sowieso nächste Woche hätte weg müssen äh weg müssen können, äh quasi ungültig macht, und da was reinsteckt, ne? Es werden auf jeden Fall viele,
Arbeitsschritte kannst du auch nur bei so vielen am Tag machen.
Ein bisschen mehr Zeit als jetzt sofort, weil jetzt sofort sind die Dinger halt,
und müssen halt äh jetzt möglichst zeitnah ausgetauscht.
Einem natürlich schon so vor, dass die dass es jetzt, sage ich mal, in ihr eigenes finanzielles Interesse gespielt hat, dieses Problem nicht zu lösen.
Absolut. Also ich meine, wir sprechen da über krass krass viel Geld. Fucking dreihundert, 400 Millionen Euro in einem also gut, das ist jetzt vielleicht fürs Gesundheitssystem nicht so eine ganz heftige Summe.
Für die, die das Geld verdienen, ist das wahrscheinlich ganz okay.
Ja für die, die das verdienen, ist das eigentlich ein ganz willkommenes Geschäft. Also die verdienen da halt echt gut Knete mit, ne?
Aber also.
Weil ich meine, was was haben die denn, was was äh,
welcher Wertschöpfungsprozess findet da eigentlich statt? Die Hersteller, wenn sie das Gerät auslöschen, die Hersteller nehmen sich einfach ein Produkt, was sie bereits fertig entwickelt haben aus dem Regal, installieren das auf irgendeinen billigen.
Kriegst noch nicht mal ein Geräte-Upgrade, du kriegst das gleiche Ding nochmal.
Doch, doch, du kriegst schon ein neues.
Aber sie liefern,
einfach das Äquivalent. Es ist nichts also es ist vielleicht etwas neuer, aber es tut exakt genau das Gleiche und der einzige Unterschied zu dem anderen Gerät ist, dass das Zertifikat ein anderes Datum hat, dass er ein paar Bits anders gedreht sind.
Das heißt, sie kaufen, die kaufen sich in China.
Ist das dann gültig?
Auch wieder fünf Jahre gültig,
Ja dann wieder Austausch. Es sei denn die Gematik schafft es tatsächlich bis dahin die TE zwei Punkt null einzuführen wo dann keine Konnektoren mehr benötigt werden. Was ich übrigens bedenklich finde, weil ich finde dieses dieses,
diese Idee mit den Konnektoren ist eigentlich gar nicht so schlecht, weil das halt ein dezentrales System und so. Das äh eigentlich schon gar nicht so verkehrt.
Also wir wir gehen hin wollen schönes digitales Gesundheitssystem bauen.
Dann verpulvern wir dort.
Landen am Ende bei bei Leuten, die entweder also es gibt ja nur zwei Möglichkeiten, also entweder so in Kompetenz sind, dass sie uns ein Gerät bauen, was nur fünf Jahre hält oder so,
und böswillig, dass sie uns ein Gerät verkaufen, was nur fünf Jahre hält.
Dann verkaufen sie dir Happy ein neues. Für nur 2300 Euro, wo sie eine Software drauf installieren, die sie schon lange entwickelt haben, für das sie einfach nur einen billigen Classe Router in China einkaufen.
Für sie ja jedes Jahr günstiger wird, den nochmal zu kaufen, ja, der kostet äh.
Was kostet denn den Gemeinkauf? Also ich würde nicht wetten, dass das nicht mehr als 100 Euro kostet so eine Kiste im Einkauf.
Ich finde einiges weniger schätzen, aber äh kommt halt drauf an, was da noch so für.
Slots und so.
Also die die neue Kokobox ist tatsächlich in einem Alu Druckgussgehäuse, also insofern ist der Begriff Plastikroute leider nicht mehr ganz so zu treffen.
Okay.
Also das muss man ihnen lassen. Deswegen hatte ich jetzt mal so grob hundert, aber am Ende des Tages ist halt der Preis um 2.300 Euro komplett out of the white, das ist halt das ergibt keinen Sinn.
Und und was also was halt wirklich also der der Teil, der mich jetzt auch wirklich verwundert ist,
Wir reden die ganze Zeit von einem neusignierten Publiquin. So und der für dieses für das Zertifikat,
Das hat doch überhaupt gar keinen Geheimhaltungsnotwendigkeit, der private key, der dass der auf dieser Simm sein muss. Sorry, auf der GSMCK.
Ist im SIM-Kartenformat dann.
Also dass der auf der Sim sein muss, ist klar, aber den CRT-Teil, den legst du ja,
in anderen Implementierungen einfach mal gerne ins Dateisystem. Der muss doch überhaupt nicht auf diese auf diese.
Richtig. Und deswegen ist der Patch, den wir da gebaut haben, so, dass wir einfach ausm Dateisystem die Zertifikate laden.
Moment, da sind wir dann auch noch nicht. Also
Machen wir aber jetzt. Halten wir mal kurz fest. Also Geräte sind erforderlich, damit man diese Telematik-Infrastruktur teilnehmen kann. Jeder hat so was gekauft und unter anderem gibt es da einen,
kleines, digitales Stück Bitz, die sagen, ich bin gültig bis Datum und dieses Datum läuft nach fünf Jahren,
einfach so ab? Es gäbe,
Und gibt in diesem dieser ganzen digitalen Zertifikatswelt, die jetzt nix Brandneues ist, sondern die ist schon lange äh gibt, die auch,
gut abgehangen ist. Problemlos Möglichkeiten über die Ferne
mit so ah hallo, du bist es, der gleich abläuft. Ich weiß aber, dass du's bist hier. Ich aktualisiere dir dein Zertifikat. Du bist jetzt einfach weiter gültig. Wäre überhaupt gar kein Problem.
aber nicht implementiert worden.
Weil man dann nicht ein paar Millionen oder ein paar hundert Millionen Euro.
Auch immer, aber es ist halt nicht diese Funktionalität ist nicht da. Die zweite Möglichkeit, dass man sagt so, aber ihr habt ja noch ein paar Slots frei
könnte man auch einfach eine zweite Karte noch reinstecken, dann schreibt ihr das da drauf und dann erinnert ihr eure Software, weil die Software kann sich ja schon aktualisieren, ne?
Ja, es gibt eine Möglichkeit, da Softwareupdates zu installieren.
Genau, wenn Softwareupdates gibt, dann kann man ja auch sagen, okay, das Zertifikat liegt jetzt woanders. Das muss nicht auf dieser äh abgeschlossenen ähm SIM-Karte drauf sein. Also es wäre alles möglich, wird aber nicht gemacht.
Die Gematik hat das sogar selber sich schon einmal ausgedacht und spezifiziert diese Laufzeitverlängerung.
sogar vorgeschrieben für ein bestimmtes Update-Level von T-Connect. Aber dann hat man sich am 282. in der Vertreterversammlung einfach
entschlossen, das nicht länger vorzuschreiben und damit beschlossen, dass alle Konnektoren ausgetauscht werden müssen.
Aha. Also wir äh wollten, es wurde einfach politisch beschlossen, dass jetzt nochmal 400 Millionen Euro ausgegeben werden sollen für nichts.
Obwohl sie selber wissen, dass es nicht notwendig ist, ja.
Wollt ihr Arbeit oder wollt ihr Geld? Ja ist doch schon klar, welche Entscheidung,
Beteiligten dann treffen.
Man muss dazu sagen, äh die Sekunde und die äh Rice haben das auch tatsächlich so implementiert. Es ist nur die CGM, ähm die das nicht implementiert hat, dieses Feature auf
Verlängerung und die CGM zeigt dann drauf na ja müssen wir ja nicht weil die Thematik tatsächlich am 282. gesagt hat ja müsst ihr nicht.
Dieses Jahres.
Diesen Jahres, ja.
Heißt das, die Sekunde sagt, wir wir machen euch ein Update?
Ich weiß nicht, was er jetzt gerade äh die Sekunde macht, aber es wäre Sekunde natürlich schon total blöd zu sagen, ja wir machen ein Update, sondern wenn halt ausgetauscht wird und man da 2.300 Euro dran verdienen kann, würde ich sagen.
wir haben da Probleme mit dem äh Update festgestellt. Wir müssen leider doch die Konnektoren es leider.
Ist sicherer.
Sicherer, sicher, sicher.
Wo kommen jetzt die Hacker ins Spiel?
Ja normalerweise machen die Hacker ja immer so Sachen kaputt. So und das stand auch tatsächlich an erster Stelle bevor wir das erstmal heile machen.
Also es ist eine Behauptung, dass Hacker immer alles kaputt machen.
Ja, das ist immer so, gerade aus der aus dem Gamatikumfeld und aus dem Gesundheitsdaten verarbeitenden Gewerbe kommt immer so, ah, dieser Kack-Datenschutz und so und immer machen die was kaputt. Heute haben wir mal was heile gemacht.
Genau, weil äh Hacken heißt ja auch kreativer Umgang mit Technologie.
Und du hast dich jetzt sozusagen äh rangesetzt auch in mit Unterstützung noch von ein paar äh anderen ausm Club,
und äh habt überlegt, okay, das Ding kann sich also nicht selber aktualisieren und das Zertifikat kann äh sich nicht ähm neu machen. Gibt's vielleicht,
andere Wege. Welchen Weg bist du denn da gegangen.
Wir haben äh erstmal so einen Konnektor aufgeschraubt, um erstmal zu verstehen, was hat man da überhaupt.
Kam der her?
Das ist egal. Also man kann sich halt also lag so rum, ist vom Laster gefallen.
So, dann haben wir das Ding mal aufgeschraubt und festgestellt, ach scheiße, ist ja ein verstitzeltes Dateisystem. Also jetzt zum Anfang der Analyse stand ein,
mit dem angefangen, weil ich von der Coco Box echt wirklich verärgert war, dass man für so eine Ramschartware irgendwie so krass viel Geld verlangen kann. Also da ist in einem X6,
Das wurde original ausgeliefert mit einem Obunto elf. Das ist jetzt wirklich.
Also Übersetzung uralt.
Das ist halt Steinzeitalter Hardware, so. Die funktioniert aber immer noch weiterhin, also,
die ist zwar alt, aber die ist okay und die funktioniert und die ist für den Anwendungszweck auch hinreichend dimensioniert. So, wir haben das Ding aufgeschraubt und haben festgestellt, Scheiße, verschlüsseltes Dateisystem und äh dann,
wie kommt man denn da dran so und ähm haben festgestellt, okay man braucht die GSMCK dafür. Die hat eine PIN,
und äh die wird aus zwei unterschiedlichen Art und Weisen berechnet,
Die wird bei dem Secret Connector wird die aus den Seriennummern äh von den berechnet.
das hat mein Freund äh hat das in einmal nachiplementiert, womit man wie man die PIN berechnet. Zusätzlich war es auch möglich, die PIN einfach.
Woher wusstet ihr, wie man die Pinn berechnet, wenn das äh der Teilsystem verschlüsselt war?
Das ist äh so Hacker Magie, nein Scherz. Ähm Teile des Detailsystems waren unverschlüsselt.
Der nämlich dann am Ende.
Irgendwie muss die Kiste ja auch hochfahren so und dieses was halt beim Hochfahren die Festplatte entschlüsselt haben wir uns halt angeschaut.
Da sieht man dann irgendwann, wo greift das zu, das das sagt sich die Seriennu lässt sich die Seriennummer von dem,
im Kartenlesegerät sagen oder wo dann wahrscheinlich noch eine von dem von dem von der CPU oder so und äh nimmt dann am Ende nimmt sich daraus vier Zahlen und schickt die halt an den,
Smartcut äh.
Was da passiert ist, der liest äh ausm SÜFS, aus USB-Devices lalala, die Seriennummern von den Geräten. Ähm,
mache da noch so ein bisschen Bittgewürfel da drauf und hat dann die Pin für die GSMCK. Das ist jetzt der Sicconnect Connector.
bei dem bei der Coco Box sieht das Ganze sehr ähnlich aus
Da wird allerdings die PIN einfach außen,
System gelesen. Also die befindet sich dann im festen Offset auf diesem EMMT-Chip
beim bei der Coco Box war's ein bisschen trickyer, der erstmal in das Dateisystem ranzukommen.
befandet sich äh befand sich nämlich auch so ein EMC-Chip. Das heißt, ähm den hat ein Freund von mir ausgelötet und ausgelesen ist ein kleines Steinchen, so ein BGA-Stein. Muss man gut für löten können, besser als ich löten kann,
Er hat mir Jasek geholfen. Der hat das ausgelesen und ähm dort gab's dann auch so ein so ein was halt beim Hochfahren ausgeführt wird, um die Festplatte die verschlüsselte Mountain zu können.
So und dafür sagt er einfach zu der PIN hier äh äh zu der zu der Karte hier Pin, gib mal bitte äh Schlüssel so und so oder hier ich gebe dir mal was, entschlüssel mir das mal bitte.
Genau Letzteres.
Genau und damit Wasser dann zurückkriegt, damit kann er sich den Rest des Dateisystems dann bootstrappen.
Richtig. Ähm bei der Coco Box wird dabei ein Looks verwendet. Kennst du sicherlich von Linux. Ähm
die ähm die die Kiste von der Sekunde verwendet dabei ein DM Krypt Sina Modul. Das heißt sie haben sich da irgendwie Krypto selber gebaut. Ich weiß nicht, ob das die Krypto ist, die auch in so Sina-Boxen drin ist.
Spannende Frage, weiß ich nicht und ähm genau, damit hatten wir dann im Prinzip voll Zugriff auf diesen Konnektor.
Und damit habt ihr das vollzurufen auf den Connector. Das heißt, damit habt ihr jetzt einen könnt ihr jetzt ein Dateisystem lesen, ein verschlüsseltes Das Heilsystem, wo sich offensichtlich oder offenbar ein Linux drauf befindet oder irgendein unixartiges.
Da muss man auch noch mal ein bisschen unterscheiden. Der und die Coco Box haben bisschen andere Architektur. Ähm,
Bei der Siconette ist das Ganze so, dass die Anwendung an sich auch verschlüsselt ist. Das heißt, es war notwendig, an diese verschlüsselte Partition ranzukommen
oben verstehen zu können, wie ähm der Konnektor funktioniert
bei der Coco Box, weil lediglich ähm die Konfigurations-Partition verschlüsselt. Das heißt, äh die Sekunde hatte da halt mehr Interesse scheinbar an dem Schutz der eigenen.
Hatten wir dann äh die Software, aber auch die ähm verschlüsselte Partition, also die Konfig Partition, vorliegen,
äh konnten diesen Konnektor in der virtuellen Maschine ausführen, indem wir den Inhalt äh dann die Smart Card,
in diese VM halt reinreichen in den USB wieder. Und damit halt nachvollziehen, wie die Kiste funktioniert. So und dann haben wir einen Patch gebaut.
und dieser Patch, der setzt äh relativ low Level an ähm die,
Anwendung von dem Hersteller kann einfach so bestehen bleiben. Wir tauschen einfach nur so eine Linux Komponente auseinander. Linux gibt.
Smartcut real.
Genau, die Smartcard Readersoft,
und zwar haben wir aus dem so klassischerweise so ein PCS-CD, um irgendwie mit Smartkarten zu kommunizieren, der macht ein Unique Socket auf und wenn du dann als Anwendung irgendwie mit der Smartkarte irgendwas machen willst, dann verbindest du dich mit diesem Unique Socket und kannst mit äh
wenn du unabhängig mit irgendeiner Smartcard kommunizieren.
Also PCS-CD, der PC Smartcard Diemen ja eine.
Standardsoftware.
Die, wenn du einen hast funktioniert auch glaube ich für NFC-Bereiche,
der einfach sagt, pass auf, ich gebe dir hier eine ich gebe dir hier eine Schnittstelle ähm die hat Slots oder die unterscheidet Slots. Wenn du jetzt hier drei hast, redest du immer noch über glaube ich das gleiche socket, sagst du einfach nur, ich will mit.
Der anderen Karte reden. Genau.
Anderen Karte sprechen und ich schicke dir jetzt mal dieses und jenes Kommando.
Theoretisches, glaube ich, in dem Smartkartenprotokoll auch denkbar, dass man mehrere Smartkarten an einem Slot hat, aber äh ja,
Also ich hatte da auf jeden Fall Hilfe von Leuten, die sich sehr gut mit Smartkarten auskennen. Das war nämlich für mich ein äh neues Thema. Da hatte mir Pommes äh sehr beigeholfen. Viel lieben Dank an der Stelle.
Der sich seit wahrscheinlich 20 Jahren mit den Dingern jeden Tag hin in größter Tiefe auseinandersetzt.
Von Open Java Card, hatten wir auch mal kurz überlegt, ob man so eine Anwendung auch einfach so eine GSMCK nachbauen kann.
Ist durchaus möglich, also es wäre auch möglich, dass wir dann da irgendwie so Karten für bereitstellen, mit denen man die dann austauschen kann. Aber genau, also hm,
Der Patch setzte bei diesem Smartkartendiam an und wir tauschen ihn einfach aus. Also wir lassen den vom Hersteller weiterlaufen im Hintergrund, denn von dem wissen wir ja, dass er mit den Smartkarten Interfacen kann, dass er funktioniert, so für die,
wieder, die da verbaut sind. Wir starten unseren eigenen Smartkarten-Deal und alles, was ihr macht, ist alle Befehle an die Smart-Karte durchreichen. Außer,
jetzt diese Zertifikatsdatei gelesen werden soll. Also man muss sich das so vorstellen, so eine Smartcard, die hat ein Dateisystem,
nicht so ein Ex vier oder NTFS oder so was, sondern man muss sich das mehr sowieso logisch wie so ein Dateisystem vorstellen und der Konnektor liest, wenn er hochfährt, äh dieses Zertifikat aus.
um dann mit dem dazugehörigen Private Keent, den er natürlich nicht auslesen kann, da gibt's dann nur so APIs hier, so nach dem Motto signieren wir das mal oder entschlüsseln wir mal was. Ähm.
Damit zu operieren. Genau. Der liest halt ihnen jetzt halt diese Zertifikate aus und da machen wir dann eine Grätsche in die Kommunikation rein, die übrigens nicht irgendwie geschützt oder verschlüsselt ist. Deswegen können wir da reingrätschen und wenn diese Zertifikatsdatei ausgelesen werden soll,
Dann antworten wir einfach mit unserer verlängerten Zertifikatsdatei. Wohlgemerkt, dass es nur der öffentliche Teil, nicht der private, der Private kann weiter auf der Karte leben. So,
und dann senden wir da einfach die das verlängerte Zertifikat. Das muss natürlich noch signiert werden. So, das muss ja von der CA ausgestellt werden.
Wollte gerade sagen, also es ist also als als Konzept macht's äh macht's Sinn, aber äh ihr müsstet jetzt eigentlich also mehr als ein Proof of Concept kann es nicht sein, weil,
Ihr bräuchtet jetzt erstmal verlängerte Zertifikate. Die müsst ihr euch die GEMATIQ ausstellen.
Richtig. Also die äh Zertifikate, die ich hier auf diesem GSMCKs finden konnte, das sind drei Stück jeweils immer. Die waren alle von der Gamatik ausgestellt. Das heißt, die GEMAtik wäre auch in der Lage, diese Zertifikate dann entsprechend zu verlängern, also neu auszustellen.
und ähm die bräuchte es an der Stelle dann halt, um dieses Zertifikat auszustehen. In unserem Profo of Concept haben wir natürlich einfach eine Fake-CA verwendet, die wir uns halt einfach ausgedacht haben.
Nur zeigen, dass es von.
Richtig, genau.
Und ihr müsstet noch ein Problem haben, ich wäre verwundert, wenn ihr ein dermaßenen Eingriff in die Integrität des Systems machen könnt, ohne irgendwie Secure-Boot oder irgendwelche Integritätschecks zu verletzen.
Ganz richtig. Äh wir können dieses Update nicht installieren, außer halt auf äh sehr aufwendig präparierten Konnektoren.
sondern ähm was da passieren muss, ist der Hersteller muss sich unseren Patch nehmen, den wir ja unter einer freien Lizenz zur Verfügung stellen. Das heißt, der äh der Hersteller darf das tun.
gerne. Also ich würde mich freuen, wenn das äh am Ende des Tages tatsächlich hilft, 400 Millionen zu sparen. Benutzt es, ähm.
Es spart ja nicht denen 400 Millionen. Das ist ja, glaube ich, die Falle.
Gehe ja gerade noch davon aus, dass die Hersteller am Allgemeinwohl interessiert sind und so.
Wie die Ärzte auch, die sind ja auch daran interessiert, dass.
Ich ich würde mal gerne noch unsere normal äh sterblichen äh Hörerinnen mit rein äh holen um mal kurz zusammenfassen, äh was wir jetzt eigentlich gerade hier dargelegt haben. Also
Das Problem ist, dieses Zertifikat läuft einfach aus. Das haben wir ja äh vorhin auch schon äh besprochen und es sollte das nicht tun. Und es gibt durchaus Mittel und Wege, so ein Zertifikat zu verlängern,
nur kommen wir da von außen nicht ran, was ihr jetzt gemacht habt ist, ihr habt euch diese Hardware,
in dem Fall zwei von drei, die so auf dem Markt sind, wenn ich das richtig sehe. Mal genauer äh angeschaut und Mittel und Wege gefunden durch dieses ganze
Daten und Verschlüsselungsdickicht äh durchzugehen, um am Ende eine kleine Komponente auszutauschen, die einfach diesen Zugriff auf dieses Zertifikat kurz abfängt und sagt,
Moment, ich habe da was anderes für.
Das heißt, es wäre ein sehr kleiner Eingriff, was dann der Hersteller als Update bereitstellen kann.
Das elegante, also ich habe als als wir das erste Mal erzählt hast, habe ich auch so ein bisschen gedacht so na ja okay,
auf gewisse Weise so ein bisschen von hinten durch die Brust ins Auge, so ein bisschen billig, also es ist so ein kleiner Heck, ne, aber von hinten durch die Brust ins Auge ist das Problem,
dass man überhaupt so einen kleinen Hack anwenden muss, der ist aber aus einer Security-Perspektive absolut vertretbar, weil der in keiner Form die Integrität des Systems verletzt, ja? Selbst wenn da jetzt also das das Schlimmste, was du damit machen könntest,
wäre, dass da dass da ein nicht gültiges Zertifikat liegt, was dann halt von der Gamatik nicht akzeptiert wird?
Das wäre das das Allerschlimmste.
Wir hantieren an der Stelle nur mit öffentlichen Daten. Also.
Äh genau, also.
Sind halt öffentlich und die private bleiben halt weiter auf den Karten liegen so.
Also die Interität des Systems bleibt 100 Prozent erhalten, die Sicherheit des Systems bleibt 100 Prozent erhalten.
Wir müssen das nicht aufschrauben. Das wird einfach als Update Datei. Da müsste der Hersteller halt nochmal einspringen. Da müsste dieses Update signieren, denn wir können halt nicht einfach so Software installieren, das kann nur der Hersteller. So.
Mit anderen Worten, wenn die mitspielt und wenn die Hersteller äh mitspielen und man sagt so, hör mal Leute, lasst uns doch das mal so lösen, könnte man jetzt allein äh über das Netz,
automatisch, ohne dass man in irgendeine Praxis reingehen muss, an irgendeinem Gerät rumschrauben muss,
von außen diese Modifikationen vornehmen,
Und man müsste nicht 400 Millionen Euro den Praxen erstatten, damit sie
ein Gerät austauschen, nur um diese paar Bits äh umzuwerfen, man könnte diese Bits einfach von außen umwerfen und alle werden glücklich, weil es würde sehr viel schneller gehen und man würde sich insgesamt Geld sparen, was man dann äh.
Ja, man muss das olle Gerät nicht austauschen, das heißt, die Konfiguration in der Arztpraxis bleibt erhalten, das heißt, man hat keine Folgekosten.
dieses Update jetzt aus der Ferne installiert werden kann, das weiß ich nicht. Also es könnte sein, dass der Arzt dann sich auf seinem Konnektor anmelden muss und das,
einspielen muss. Aber das ist ein Prozess, der existiert, weil die Geräte müssen ja ohnehin gepatcht werden so.
Einfache Problemlösung.
Wenn auch sozusagen von der Praxis aus injiziert, aber halt übers Netz. Man holt sich sozusagen einfach eine Aktualisierung rein und schon muss man die ganze Hardware nicht mehr austauschen.
Genau. Äh vielleicht was wir in unserem Patch jetzt noch nicht demonstriert haben, aber was trivial möglich ist, ist diese Zertifikatsdateien, die müssen ja erstmal irgendwo herkommen.
So da müsste man dann müsste dann ein Hersteller, wenn er einen Patch baut, noch irgendwie einen kleinen,
Befehl reinbauen, dass er sich halt irgendwie dieses Zertifikat dann von irgendeiner zentralen Stelle runterlädt. Wie gesagt, das ist nicht geheim, das kann man einfach übers Internet machen.
Authentifiziert sich ja sogar über das Zertifikat.
Ist ja am Ende des Tages ist das total Ralle, ob er sich authentifiziert oder nicht, weil es sei einfach eine öffentliche Information.
Genau, ist richtig, aber du hättest, du hast halt die also du hast du kannst sicher sein oder du kannst sicherstellen, dass du nicht aus Versehen jemandem das falsche Zertifikat gibst. Das wäre halt tödlich.
Ja, richtig. Nö, wer ja, es wäre halt, dann würde der Konnektor nicht funktionieren.
Genau, dann dann aber ne, dann würde sich der Konnektor beim nächsten Mal nicht mehr verbinden können, weil es falsche Zertifikat hat, aber weil der Konnektor ja im Zweifelsfall wirklich mit dir verbunden ist,
der ist das. Der hat sich ausgewistet, der ist im Besitz genau dieses Schlüsselpaares,
Ich gebe dem jetzt einfach ein verlängertes Zertifikat, wie gesagt, was sich um wenige handverlesene Bits von dem ändert, was er ohnehin schon hat.
Der Aufwand, den jetzt die Hersteller hätten und die die hätte,
Wenn man den jetzt mal so in irgendwelchen ich will's jetzt nicht in in in Manntagen oder so was äh aufrechnen, aber das es würde nicht 400 Millionen Euro kosten, diese Software äh diesen Softwareprozess einzuleiten.
Es wäre jetzt also ich,
jetzt mal so sagen, so so ein Proof of Concept zu machen. Ich weiß nicht, habt ihr jetzt wahrscheinlich ein paar Tage oder Wochen,
dran gearbeitet, weil ihr ja auch forschen musstet, ja, weil ihr viele Sachen,
Weg räumen musstet, bis er überhaupt erstmal an den Punkt kam, dass das funktionieren kann.
Ganz richtig. Also das Reverse-Engineering hat bei weitem am längsten gedauert. Äh Annika hatte dann die
Software dafür programmiert, eine Canik und das ging an einem Tag, also halben Tag war die Patch fertig. Ein Hersteller, der die ganze Dokumentation hat und weiß, was er da gebaut hat, der kann das ähnlich schnell machen.
Musste dir noch helfen zu verstehen, an welchem Call genau der ja.
Ja, genau. Wie da überhaupt die Dateisystemen Zugriffe auf so eine Smartcard aussehen ähm wie dieses Dateisystem überhaupt funktioniert, wie überhaupt eine Smartkartenkommunikation, dies, das, Ananas.
Aber ihr, ihr wart ja nicht die Hersteller. Ihr musstet das alles erst rausfinden. Die wissen ja, wie das geht.
selber gebaut. Was wäre der Aufwand jetzt für einen Hersteller diesen Patch, diese Idee, dieses Proof of Concept, das ihr jetzt äh rausgebracht habt, konkret umzusetzen?
Ich würde dreist behaupten eine Woche, kriegt ein Hersteller das hin.
Man könnte sagen, es gibt jetzt nicht 400 Millionen Euro für ganz neue Geräte und deren Austausch. Sondern wir zahlen euch irgendwie eine Woche Arbeit und dann war's das.
Ja die Woche Arbeit also.
Ich würde den am besten gar nix bezahlen, weil die halt äh versucht haben mit den 400 Millionen durchzukommen und zu bestrafung würde ich dieses kostenlos machen.
Man muss ja auch Kompromisse eingehen.
Eine eine Woche Implementierung für jetzt die äh Software auf dem auf dem Router ist die eine Sache, ja dann Software bereitstellen, testen ist natürlich bei so einer Sache noch mal viel.
Ja, geben geben wir den Monat.
Gehen wir im Monat gehen wir auch mehrere Personen, ja,
und dann noch nicht zu vergessen irgendwie 'ne Infrastruktur dann,
einen Prozess bauen, dass sich dieser,
diese neue eben auch stabil,
neues Zertifikat geben lässt und das Richtige, ja? Also wenn man das jetzt mal mit dem,
mit dem oder mit der mit der gebotenen Sorgfalt und dem Testing macht äh würde ich schätzen, ist das in einem Monat umsetzbar mit einem,
wahrscheinlich mehrere Personen umfassenden Team, ja? Und dann haben die eine wahrscheinlich tausende Prozesse, die sie noch irgendwie im im Rahmen,
der äh Sorgfaltspflicht beziehungsweise das Budget aufblasens äh noch machen und dann müssen sie jeden Tag nochmal mit einer Projektmanagerin telefonieren oder so einen Scheiß, aber es ist eine absolut äh privile Aufgabe, die am Ende,
wie viel Zeilen-Code an dem Konnektor ändert? Also.
Muss ich nachschauen, wieviel sein Code da.
Vom Bauch her.
Zweihundert.
Das ist nicht viel.
Und wenn der Hersteller das macht, der kann ja ähm an einer viel höheren Level eigentlich noch eingreifen und die Zertifikatsdatei austauschen. Wir haben hier nur so low level angesetzt, weil ähm,
wir nicht so genau wissen, wo diese Zertifikate jetzt überall in der Software benutzt werden und es halt,
Am Ursprung äh auszutauschen und reinzugrätschen ist ja eigentlich am umfassendsten und deck,
alles ab, wenn der Hersteller so einen Patch baut, der kann wahrscheinlich einfach sich sein, der weiß ja, wie seine Software funktioniert und da wo er irgendwie den Zugriff auf die Smart Card macht, kann er einfach äh das Zertifikat ausm Faltsystem lesen so, also
Der Hersteller könnte dann noch einen viel einfacheren Patch bauen, so der dann.
Wäre so viel einfacher, weil der wird wahrscheinlich an vielen verschiedenen ah nee, wird er ja nicht, ist ja nur einmal.
Genauso ist es einmal gelesen und die anderen werden glaube ich auch einmal gelesen so. Wenn sie schlau sind, lesen sie's nur einmal.
Äh ich bin wirklich also ich bin wirklich fasziniert davon, weil ich ja beruflich mit genauso etwas zu tun hatte. Da der war mir von diesem Konnektorenkram,
noch gar nicht bekannt und dann habe ich haben wir uns genau darüber Gedanken gemacht, dass wie lösen wir dieses Problem in potenziell 20 Jahren, ja und haben das schon mal dokumentiert, wenn wir niemals in den Sinn gekommen zu sagen, voll geil,
das vorher lass uns das Problem einfach in fünf Jahren haben und in den gleichen Scheiß nochmal zu verkaufen. Ähm,
Es gibt jetzt noch einen einen kleinen Punkt, mit dem ich dich konfrontieren muss Flipke?
Und das ist, wenn diese Dinger irgendwie zwischen oder um die fünf Jahre alt sind jetzt,
dann würde ich mal tippen bei Leuten, die den Konnektor bauen, deren wo sie wissen, die muss nach fünf Jahren wegwerfen,
Die geben dir wahrscheinlich auch die in diesen Bereichen üblichen Verschlüsselungs,
äh Typen und Schlüsselängen, sodass du wahrscheinlich irgendwie,
mit RSA Schlüssel in der hantierst, die nicht notwendigerweise äh über dreitausend Bit haben, sondern wahrscheinlich eher,
20achtundvierzig, was äh was halt total üblich ist, vor allem auch bei so SIM-Modulen, die fünf, sechs Jahre alt sind oder wahrscheinlich in dem Fall 8 Jahre, weil sie nicht die neuesten genommen haben.
Richtig,
Genau das. Also das wird auch wahrscheinlich die Hauptargumentationslinie der Hersteller sein. Ja, aber wir haben ja nur 2048 Bit verbaut. Da muss man mal kritisch fragen, wieso habt ihr damals noch nicht auf Elektro Club Tourgraphy gesetzt? Die Gematik hat es euch soweit ich weiß,
offen gelassen oder ihr hättet auch schon mal irgendwie hochwertigere Smartkarten verbauen können. Das Gerät ist so unendlich teuer. Das sind irgendwie eine leicht bessere Smartkarte jetzt irgendwie,
wäre noch drin gewesen. Ähm aber.
Zu sagen also warum wir das ansprechen, es gibt für unterschiedliche Schlüssellängen vom BSI was ja wahrscheinlich für die Gamatik eine sehr relevante Institution ist.
Also es kommt drauf an, ne. Also die ist
die das BSI macht nicht rechtsverbindliche Vorschriften. Und mal hält sich die Gematik da sehr pingelig dran, wie jetzt zum Beispiel mit den Konnektortausch und zeigt hier das BSI sagt hier 2048 bit
das fliegt nicht mehr ab zwanzig vierundzwanzig
und mal macht das Baesie wirklich sehr konkrete Vorgaben, zum Beispiel wie die elektronische Patientenakte verschlüsselt zu sein hat und dann hält sich die GEMAtik halt einfach nicht dran. So und wenn du dann gehst du zum BSI und dann sagt das BSI na das.
So nicht gut, aber jetzt
in dem Fall, wenn es wenn es für sie eine Ausrede ist, 400 Millionen vielleicht doch zu bekommen, äh werden sich wahrscheinlich daran äh orientieren,
wir sind jetzt wir wollen auch nicht diejenigen sein, die sagen, ihr könnt eure äh 2tausendachtundvierzig Bitschlüssel noch nennenswert länger reiten als das BSI vorgibt. Wobei ich ehrlich gesagt,
sagen würde, dass sie jetzt nicht äh unbedingt zwanzig, 24 schlagartig schlecht werden.
Richtig. Man muss auch noch dazu sagen, dass die Daten, die halt innerhalb dieses VPNs kommuniziert werden, natürlich auch nochmal verschlüsselt sind. Also am Ende des Tages äh sprechen die da drinne TLS. Das heißt, man kann da einfach äh,
und das ist auch jetzt schon der Fall. Da wird mit TLS eine bessere Suite als erst A2048 verwendet. Ähm ich möchte dich jetzt aber auch nicht öffentlich hinstellen und irgendwie zwanzig achtundvierzig
total lobpreisen und sagen, ja okay, hier kann man das schon mal machen, ihm die Augen zudrücken, sondern äh was ich vorhin schon mal angedeutet hatte,
kann diese GSMCKs austauschen. Eine muss drinne bleiben, damit wir weiterhin irgendwie die Smart Card äh quatscht, damit wir das das,
richtig, das Hotelsystem entschlüsseln können. Aber wir haben ja noch zwei weitere Slots. So und dann steckt man da einfach zwei,
hochwertigere Smartcards rein, die genug Dampf haben ähm
dass das vorher die drei smarten Karten geschafft haben zurzeit zu machen und die können dann halt,
oder 496 Bit,
Da würde ich übrigens direkt auf äh viertausend6undneunzig gehen und nicht diese Zwischenstufe dreitausend, die dann auch wieder irgendwann fertig ist, sondern da würde ich gleich auf etwas Zukunftsfähiges gehen. Äh
Ja, muss man ja dazu sagen, sonst haben wir in in fünf Jahren hier wieder das gleiche Thema auf der Tagesordnung stehen.
Muss natürlich sagen, also diese BSI-technischen Richtlinie, die haben, glaube ich, immer also das Höchste, was sie dir versprechen, ist 2028 Plus.
Also das ist BSI natürlich auch äh sage ich mal vorsichtig genug, dass ihnen ihre technischen Richtlinien nicht irgendwie rückblickend betrachtet betrachtet, doof aussehen. Ähm.
Die sind da sehr konservativ. Also ist auch gut so und das ist die Aufgabe von dem Bassy absolut. Ähm wir gewinnen jetzt Zeit, wenn man sich an.
Um die zwei Jahre gewinnen, wenn man jetzt mit so einem Patch arbeitet,
in zwei Jahren ähm zu sagen wir wir machen entsprechende Upgrades, dass sie mit neueren Smartkarten vernünftig reden. Ähm wir nehmen uns dann die Zeit die zu tauschen.
Richtig, das kann man auch von mir ausm Feld machen, so dass wir durchaus möglich. Ich könnte mir das so vorstellen, dass dann irgendwelche Techniker durchs durch die Arztpraxen tingeln und
nicht den Konnektor austauschen, sondern den Konnektor eben aufschrauben, dabei brechen sie natürlich das Siegel, das heißt sie brauchen irgendwie Siegelfolie, müssen dokumentieren, dass sie den Konnektor frisch versiegelt haben, kriegen irgendwie frische Smartkarten, haben dann irgendwie da noch eine
Pin, die sie lustig irgendwie freirubbeln können, dass dann in die äh UI eintippen und dann das Ganze halt propper dokumentieren, wie sie da die Smart Card drin ausgetauscht haben. Fertig.
Das ist sicherlich nicht günstig, aber es ist mit Sicherheit günstiger als den ganzen Konnektor für 2.300 Euro auszutauschen.
Ja, das äh kommt natürlich auf die Rahmenverträge an. Nein, das ist aber es.
So eine Smartcard kostet 30 Euro. Also die Gematik verkauft die auch für so Testzwecke. Endkundenpreis aber. Ja genau.
Endkundenpreis aber ja ich wollte gerade sagen, wenn du wenn du 130.000 davon bestellst kosten die äh nicht sofort.
Ja, absolut, absolut. Da auch eine lustige Feststory. Ich habe bei der Gamatik angefragt, ob sie mir so eine GSMCK
schicken können. Die haben so einen Webshop, wo sie irgendwie so Smartkarten verkaufen, so SMCB und HBA. Natürlich ich mit
Produktivdaten, sondern halt für deren Test- und Referenzumgebung. Haben sie mir geschrieben, jo, haben wir lieferbar, kosten 30 Euro, irgendwie so um den Dreh. Ähm
Sagen Sie uns, wie viel Sie haben wollen. Dann habe ich da von einer anderen E-Mail noch mal geschrieben und gesagt, ja guten Tag. Ich hätte ganz gerne hier mal so einen Stapel fünf Stück.
Ja ähm äh sind nicht lieferbar. Und nee, erst hieß es, hier Sie finden auf unserer Webseite unser ganzes Angebot. Dann habe ich noch mal eine E-Mail geschrieben mit,
Da habt ihr aber gesagt, dass die lieferbar sind und dann waren sie halt plötzlich auf einmal irgendwie nicht lieferbar.
Äh also lag es daran, dass du als Flipke gefragt hast, dass die dann nicht mehr liefern, aber.
Interessanterweise hatte ich vorher als Flöckke At Berlin angefragt und dann über meine Company E-Mail-Adresse, aber,
Unklar. Ähm jedenfalls
man kann diese GSMTKs austauschen, ähm man kann dafür einen Prozess bauen, die auszutauschen, der ist auch nicht sonderlich kompliziert und es ergeben sich vielleicht auch noch andere Lösungsmöglichkeiten, denn solche Chips, die sie da verbaut haben, die haben in aller Regel auch wie so ein
PM mit drinne oder irgendwie ein Secure-Element und dann könnte man auch mal noch evaluieren, was da eigentlich so geht.
Die sind gerne auch mal so noch auf auf 2048 oder geringe Subsets von ECDSA-Möglichkeiten beschränkt, aber
evaluieren kann man's auf jeden Fall irgendwas äh irgendwas ECDSA will die erreichen.
Richtig,
also Eleptic have to prography sollte eigentlich in allen modernen TPMs aber ich will mich da jetzt auch nicht zu weit aus dem Fenster legen. Also man gewinnt auf jeden Fall Zeit und diese Zeit kann man halt benutzen, zu evaluieren, was kann die Hardware, die wir da haben, kann man die vielleicht noch irgendwie einsetzen mit einem Softwareup
oder müssen wir jetzt tatsächlich Techniker in die Arztpraxen schicken und die ähm GSMCKs austauschen lassen.
Ein kleines Fazit äh ziehen oder ich würde das gerne mal tun so ein,
Also,
Die ganze Gamatik, Infrastruktur ist teilweise ganz gut, aber teilweise auch fragwürdig, äh was sie uns letzten Endes liefern soll, so oder so, gibt es die Verpflichtungen derzeit noch diese Konnektoren zu haben. Die laufen jetzt aus,
Und nur weil irgendwelche Bits umfallen soll quasi das gesamte Gesundheitssystem hier nochmal 400 Millionen Euro versenken.
Die die ganze Gamatik könnte auch einfach kollektiv die Uhren zurückstellen. Das wäre äh wäre übrigens auch noch so eine Lösung, ne.
Ihr könnt ja auch einfach sagen, wir akzeptieren das jetzt länger. Ich meine, was wäre denn.
Einfach äh.
Wer wer überprüft denn dieses diese Zertifikatsgültigkeit? An welcher Stelle wird denn das.
IP-Sex Server.
Mehrere Stellen tatsächlich, also ähm.
Auch in dem Konnektor selber.
Also es ist kompliziert.
Weiß das geil. Also der Konnektor dem ist es relativ egal, ob das gültig ist oder nicht. Der präsentiert das erstmal am anderen Ende.
Richtig. Also in diesem Konnektor stecken drei Zertifikate, die aber alle das gleiche Ablaufdatum haben,
So ähm der eine ist halt für die VPN, für das Ipsack. Da ist kein Thema, könnte man halt die Uhr zurückstellen oder den halt auf Yolo konfigurieren, weiß ja gar so. Ähm,
Gibt's noch einen zweiten? Ein zweites Zertifikat. Das ist für die Kommunikation mit der Arztpraxis Software, denn auch innerhalb der Arztpraxis ist die Kommunikation TLS verschlüsselt,
und das heißt, da sind dann und und es gibt noch ein Zertifikat für die Kommunikation mit dem Kartenterminal zum Beispiel. Das heißt, es findet sehr viel Kommunikation mit anderen Systemen statt, wo man überall die Uhr zurückdrehen müsste und.
Also es ist jetzt nicht so, dass man einfach zentral irgendwo sagt,
Wir akzeptieren das jetzt einfach länger, sondern es ist einfach schwierig. Deswegen muss man diesen etwas komplizierteren Weg gehen,
ihr habt aber jetzt sozusagen einfach gezeigt, hör mal
Müssen nicht 400 Millionen Euro rausschmeißen, nur am Ende das gleiche da zu haben, was wir jetzt auch haben, sondern man kann einfach das nehmen, was da sowieso schon ist und einfach die Laufzeit verlängern und wenn ihr wirklich Bedenken habt, dass diese in diesem System
innewohnende Security ihn dann in zwei Jahren nicht mehr euren hohen Standards entspricht. Da haben wir
immer noch ein Pfad dahin, das irgendwie elegant zu lösen, aber man muss es jetzt nicht unbedingt so auf die teure Art und Weise machen.
Oma weiß ja, dass die dass die das Problem in zwei Jahren echt sicherlich lösen werden wenn sie's vorher in fünf Jahren nicht gemacht haben, ja.
das ist ja eigentlich das Traurige hier dran, warum es natürlich auch, ne, dass wir, also meine meine vorsichtige Prognose wäre,
werden das äh die werden sich werden sich jetzt wieder irgendwie winden, um zu sagen, ja äh das kann natürlich sein, dass da irgend so ein Flipke äh äh mit mit zwei, drei, vier Leuten musst du gleich übrigens auch nochmal genau, die Namen den
damit wir die hier in entsprechend würdigen.
dass da irgendwie ein paar Leute sitzen und irgendwie äh was hacken, aber einmal mit den hohen Weinen hier, da müssen wir lieber 130.000 so Dinger in Schrott werfen.
wo wir uns echt, weil sie zu Zeiten von Chipmangel, Klimawandel sollen die jetzt demnächst ins Heizkraftwerk. Vielleicht werden wir sie da sogar brauchen, ja, aber,
Also es ist doch.
Und wenn es der Gamatik wirklich um die äh Datensicherheit der Patientendaten ginge, so, ne, dann würden die nicht überall,
einbauen. Weißt du, dass du nicht konsistent auf der einen Seite zu sagen, 2048 bit sind irgendwie ab
2024 nicht mehr sicher und auf der anderen Seite würfeln sie äh private Keys server-seitig. Ist halt total albern und überhaupt nicht konkurrent. Und darüber hinaus zeigen wir ja auch, dass ähm wir die GSMTKs austauschen können, die Schlüssellänge verlängern können, dass wir damit Zeit gewinnen und zwei Jahre sind
Ich finde das realistisch. Ich finde das für eine Gamatik, also für einen Laden der Solar arschig ist wie die Gematik eher unrealistisch, aber sei es drum.
Zwei Jahre mehr als jetzt.
Aber ich also meine meine vorsichtige Prognose, schönen Gruß an unsere Hörerin bei der Gamatik. Ähm wir wissen, dass ihr das nicht machen werdet,
Und genau das wollen wir einfach mal der Welt zeigen,
Das das es geht, wo ihr sagt, es geht nicht und ihr werdet euer Leben lang damit leben müssen, äh dass er zwar die 400 Millionen bekommen habt, aber dass alle wissen, dass ihr die Bundesrepublik Deutschland verarscht habt.
damit werdet ihr alt werden müssen und äh wir werden äh damit alt werden können,
Äh zumindest so nicht unser Geld verdient haben.
Äh Philoppbuch und Netzmittel könnt ihr übrigens spenden.
Ich dachte mir auch, wenn ihr jetzt das wirklich machen nicht 400 Millionen ausgeben und da bleibt dann doch auch was übrig das könnte man ja dann so an so gemeinnützige Mekka Spaces Hackers Basis äh.
Ja, da Seenotrettung.
Auch das leider wird so einiges einfallen.
Also ja mit 400 Millionen kann man die eine das eine oder.
Gibt's auch grad noch so einen Krieg, die brauchen auch grad noch ein bisschen äh Funding, das muss man nicht alles im Plastikraucher äh.
Ja, aber am Ende des Tages ist es kommt es auch dem Gesundheitssystem. Also ich meine ist auch durchaus finanziell ange.
Auch äh sinnvoll.
Also ich wäre dafür, dass man das den Pflegekräften gibt.
Ha, super Vorschlag,
einigen wir uns. Ja sind wir durch.
Dann würde ich mich ganz gerne noch bei den Mithelfern bedanken,
bei einmal für das Auslösen, Auslösen von dem EMC, dann einmal bei Annika für das Entwickeln des Patches
sie kann sehr viel besser Python programmieren als ich. Vielen lieben Dank bei Prom für die Unterstützung bei der Smartcard, auch an CK. Vielen lieben Dank für die Unterstützung bei Smartkarten-Themen. Es muss ich noch ganz kurz nachdenken, ob ich irgendjemanden vergessen habe.
Sicherheit.
Mit Sicherheit. Ihr seid auf jeden Fall mitgemeint.
Die dir die Konnektoren haben zu.
Ja, genau.
Genannt werden können, wahrscheinlich deshalb.
Die auf jeden Fall auch. Vielen lieben Dank, dass ihr mir die zugeschickt habt. Wenn ihr zufällig einen Konnektor von der von dem Unternehmen habt, dann könnt ihr mir das gerne zuschicken. Ihr findet meine Kontaktdaten auf meinem Twitter,
Ähm ich würde auch gerne noch der Vollständigkeit halber um die Sammlung äh abzuschließen, gerne auch noch einen von der Rise zerlegen. Schickt mir so ein Gerät gerne zu,
Damit.
Hast du wahrscheinlich schon längst.
Äh einen ganzen Kartensatz tatsächlich äh da, aber halt alles für die Testumgebung. Und äh auch von der CGM tatsächlich jetzt einen
Connector für die RU zugeschickt bekommen, also für die Referenzumgebung, nicht die Produktivumgebung. Ich vermute, dass sie einfach Angst hatten, dass ich da irgendwie in der Produktivumgebung rummülle und dann da irgendwelche Kollateralschäden verursache oder so.
Noch mehr findest.
Aber mir ging's halt gar nicht darum, irgendwelche Unsicherheiten oder so bei diesem Konnektoren vorzuführen. Ich finde übrigens das Sicherheitsniveau, was ich was wir da am Ende des Tages vorgefunden haben, absolut eine Arztpraxis angemessen und muss sagen, dass es
gutes Design ist oder so. Klar, wir haben uns irgendwie demonstriert, dass man diese Festplatte entschlüsseln kann.
Aber man muss sich anschauen, mit welchem Aufwand und ich finde, dass das eine Arztpraxis durchaus angemessen ist und das
Das ist ein gutes System ist so und die Dis Engineering haben wir halt wie gesagt nur gemacht um zu zeigen, dass halt der Austausch dieser Geräte halt einfach total Quatsch ist.
Wurde wo du hinguckst, ne.
So ist die Welt. So, aber ich meine, das wird auf jeden Fall noch ein bisschen bisschen dauern, bis die digital äh Revolution sich wirklich breit macht in Deutschland. Aber du kennst ja meinen Tipp, wann das äh soweit ist, ne?
Zwanzig neunundzwanzig.
Eine nie.
Ach so.
Ich glaube nicht mehr dran. Ich glaube, wir werden dir in zehn Jahren auch sitzen,
immer noch dieselbe Situation haben. Es wird sich nichts geändert haben.
Internet ist scheiße, wir Funklöcher, Ausbau, ja, problematisch äh irgendwie voll hinterher, Platz 125 der zivilisierten Staaten irgendwie in jeder Hinsicht.
nichts wird digitalisiert sein, es werden auch Faxe durch die Gegend geschickt werden. All dieser ganze Kram, Briefen, Formulare werden irgendwie, bitte scannen Sie diesen Brief ein, drucken Sie ihn dann nochmal aus und da schreiben Sie nochmal, hinterlegen Sie in irgendeiner Ritze in der nächsten Mauer
Das das geht nicht weg. Das ist einfach, das ist.
Da sind halt nicht die Datenschützer schuld, sondern da sind halt diese digital inkompetenten Pfuscher dran Schuld, die solche Geräte bauen, die nach fünf Jahren Schrott.
Ja unter anderem, aber es ist halt, ich prangere das halt, ich denke halt einfach, dass einfach unsere Gesellschaft äh
einfach nicht up to date, also wir sind nicht frisch genug, wir sind nicht wir sind nicht in der Lage das modern äh zu denken, so das Land braucht einfach mal einen Tritt
im Arsch und äh ja,
Da wundert man sich nicht, dass die äh ihre Kinder hier nicht in deutschen Schulen schicken wollen, weil hier nix lernt. Das ist ähm ja, ist so. Gut. Vielen Dank,
das war unterhaltsam. Haben wir noch irgendwas hinterher zu werfen?
Vielleicht noch nochmal abschließend zu diesem,
Was Flipke jetzt mehrmals auch schon betont hat, ne, es sind halt nicht die Datenschützer, die die die Dinger kaputtmachen. So sind andere, die sie kaputt bauen. Und in dieser Thematik, finde ich, sieht man sehr schön so einen, so einen 8020 Prinzip, ne? Sie machen,
80 Prozent richtig, vielleicht auch neunzig, um sie auf letzten Metern noch mal mitm Arsch einzureißen,
dann irgendwo einen zentralen Schlüsselgenerierungsdienst hinzuwerfen und und damit halt so viel auch gut gemachten Kram auch einfach wieder,
Hinfällig zu machen und das ist der Teil. Wir haben da ja irgendwie nach einer der Sendung auch so ein bitterbösen nicht bitterbösen. Einen einen freundlichen äh Brief bekommen, der dann so ein bisschen mal sagte so ey ihr seid auch immer nur am Meckern,
und jetzt so ja aber es es ist ja auch wirklich weißt du so diese es ist einfach schade immer diese diese,
Fehlleitungen zu sehen und,
bin ja selber auch unglücklich und ich habe mir hier letztens, da war doch diese Veranstaltung, da waren wer war denn da Bianca,
sich da irgendwie vorwerfen lassen müsste musste durch ihr durch ihr Bestehen auf IT-Sicherheit, das würde Menschenlebenkosten von irgend so einem ehemaligen äh Gamatik-Sie so.
Der ehemalige Gematik-Chef, der sich übrigens von der Group Madic äh für eine Million ins nee ich weiß nicht wie viel Geld, ein Startup hat bezahlen lassen. Nachdem er aus der Thematik raus.
Und solche Leute sind das, ne? Solche Leute wenn das in deren Hände gibst, dann musst du dich auch nicht wundern. So und das finde ich wirklich, also diese,
Also Leute, die die die lieber 400 Millionen kassieren als dir 200 seinen Code zu liefern, das sind doch die Banditen,
Man ey, so, mach Schluss hier. Ich rege mich nur wieder auf. So, komm.
Genau. Tschüss Leute, bis bald.
Tschüss. Tschüss.
Tschüss.